[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être venu pour ce rendez
vous ce nouveau mardi de l'espace des sciences
je peux vous dire que vous avez bien fait de
venir vous allez passer une excellente soirée
vous allez comme moi apprendre beaucoup beaucoup
de choses et d'une manière très agréable c'est un
vrai plaisir de vous retrouver marc andré seul
os c'est votre deuxième visite à l'espace des
sciences de rennes la première eut lieu en 2017
au mois de novembre vous invitiez à cette époque
à un voyage au pays des microbes en résonance
avec le livre jamais seul comme sous titre ces
microbes qui construisent les plantes les animaux
les civilisations un livre paru à cette époque
donc en 2017 grand succès et grands succès mérité
vous pouvez d'ailleurs revoir cette conférence
sur notre chaîne youtube je vous invite à la
revoir parce qu'elle est elle est passionnante
puis j'en profite aussi pour saluer tous les
abonnés de plus en plus nombreux qui suivent
les conférences de l'espace des sciences sur
notre chaîne youtube et qui nous envoie des
signes encourageants très précieux pour pour moi
pour michel cabaret le directeur de l'espace des
sciences et pour toute notre équipe merci
à vous alors nous vous invitons cette fois
marc andré cela sans lien avec un nouveau livre
paru édité aussi chez chez actes sud les goûts
et les couleurs du monde avec en sous titre une
histoire naturelle des tanins de l'écologie à la
santé alors un titre un peu plus obscures a priori
mais on va on va en parler dans dans un instant un
livre que vous allez signer aussi bien sûr sur le
stand de la librairie le failler hier à l'étagé au
dessus de cette salle de conférence alors avant de
parler de ce nouveau voyage cette fois parce que
c'est encore un voyage que vous nous proposez au
pays des tanins pays un peu mystérieux je résume
rapidement votre votre itinéraire scientifique
et puis vous m'arrêtez si j'ai dit des sottises
ou si vous avez envie de compléter alors cet
itinéraire c'est celui d'un enfant parisien qui
passaient tous ses étés à belle-ile en bretagne
c'est là qu'il va apprendre à aimer la nature
vrai oui tout à fait alors très vite les études à
l'école normale supérieure rue d'ulm agrégation de
sciences de sciences naturelles à le n est ce lyon
l'école normale supérieure de lyon puis thèse dans
l'équipe de microbiologie forestière à l'inra
de nancy vous êtes nommé ensuite professeur à
l'université de montpellier puis en 2013 c'est le
retour à paris au musée romain ba voilà au muséum
comme professeur au muséum d'histoire naturelle
vous enseignez également dans d'autres universités
dans des dans les écoles normales supérieures vous
le remettre vous leurs rêves ou leur eau j arrive
pas enfin une question de fidélité au cui c'est ça
que je voulais dire merci de m'aider voyez ce que
je voulais dire oui très bien foutu m'embêterait
c'est que ces écoles ou alors je ne suis pas senti
de l'école mais comme l'école normale supérieure
de la rue d'ulm à paris puis celle de lyon
aussi un vous former en particulier les futurs
enseignants en biologie géologie vous êtes battus
pour pour que reste dans les programmes scolaires
les cours de 1.7 et qu'il ne devienne pas un peu
enfin la formation du citoyen exige pour la santé
l'alimentation et puisse avoir voté ça exige
notamment effectivement des svt pas seulement bien
sûr mais notamment et tout ce qui supprime les
bété ampute la génération à venir d'une partie de
ses espoirs et de sa façon de juger sainement ou
et puis on peut on peut s'étonner du fait que
l'on part beaucoup d'écologie d'apprendre de
réapprendre à vivre avec la nature etc puis tout
à coup on diminue considérablement les cours de sa
différence entre une posture et un engagement
bon à suivre continuez à vous battre vous est
aussi professeur aux universités de gdansk en
pologne et puis aussi en chine akon ming vous
n'allez pas y aller c'est ans il peut-être un peu
annulé la pour un mois de février vous êtes membre
de l'académie d'agriculture de france membre du
comité éditorial de la revue espèce qui est une
revue d'histoire naturelle oui parce qu'elle
vous tenez bah oui parce que ça permet d'aller
de creuser mais de creuser une façon distrayante
et d'ailleurs l'illustrateur de mon dernier livre
c'est l'illustrateur leurs vues espèces alors
cet illustrateur s'appelle arnaud raphaël ans
et vous avez bien fait de le choisir oui il a
une personnalité intéressante c'est vraiment
quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup puis c'est
surtout quelqu'un km2 d'alléger un petit peu
le blabla technique et de mettre finalement des
respirations entre les lignes vous savez très
bien aussi alléger le blabla technique vous avez
vraiment un style tout à fait agréable un style
de compteur alors vos cours vos cours porte sur
les plantes les ags les champignons da biologie
à l'écologie la biologie des interactions
et l'évolution c'est un petit peu près ça
ce sera le plus possible sur le terrain nous
est contre ça vous aimait beaucoup le terrain
et et ça vous semble très important aussi de de
transmettre cette passion aux autres oui en tout
cas d'essayer oui ouais alors le livre est bien
on va en parler juste un tout petit peu parce
que comme cette le sujet de la conférence on y
reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure je me demandais
les tanins en fait comme vous aviez un peu voulu
réhabiliter les microbes dans le livre précédent 1
expliquer à quel point ils nous sont utiles et
qui sont importants et puis son gentil puisqu'il
nous laisse jamais le seul en plus mais là de la
même façon les tanins alors les tanins que l'on
écrit avec deux n ou 1n des talents vous avez
voulu aussi les réhabiliter en montrant qu'ils
sont des acteurs majeurs de notre environnement et
qu'ils en sont peut-être les grands inconnus oui
c'était une sorte de challenge de réhabiliter les
microbes mais on vit à une époque où on commence à
concevoir qu'ils sont aussi éventuellement positif
pour nous le challenge un peu plus au dessus c'est
de donner une réputation à des inconnus et c'est
ce que j'ai essayé de faire vous allez voir que
ces inconnus en fait on les connaît très bien
mais on les a pas nommés et donc cette le but
était de montrer l'importance de quelque chose
qui va vous verrez vous jugerez vous même oui
au majeur dans notre environnement et en plus
même dans le livre vous dites qu on les étudie
peut on ne sait pas à la fac que j'ai appris ce
que j'ai mis dans le livre ça c'est sûr bon bah
on va pas en parler plus parce que j'avais un peu
noté quelques petites choses sur le livre mais je
préfère qu'on écoute la conférence avant et qu'on
y revienne ensuite entre autres je voulais dire
que vous êtes aussi un conteur vous avez vraiment
un style très agréable à découvrir et je voulais
parler des coudes ou en faisant un peu ma maligne
parce que maintenant je sais ce qu'est un coup de
grâce à vous mais je crois que vous commencez par
sa envers la conférence alors on va pas en parler
maintenant on écoute la conférence et puis après
on revient nord pour les questions et merci d'être
avec nous ce soir d'autant que demain matin
vous repartez très tôt parce que vous allez à
strasbourg où vous allez refaire le même exercice
matin vous êtes c'est important pour vous la halle
à ce genre de rencontre avec le grand public je
sais pas si c'est très utile ce que je fais mais
je remarque une chose c'est qu'on dort sur un
trésor de connaissances dans le monde dans le
monde scientifique et qu'en fait aujourd'hui
le facteur limitant n'est pas l'augmentation
de 10 à 25% de ce corpus de connaissances c'est
sa transmission vers les utilisateurs finaux ce
qu'ils ont payé leurs impôts aussi d'ailleurs au
passage et on voit bien dans un certain nombre de
choix politiques dans d'autres pays je ne parle
pas de celui-là bien sûr on voit que un certain
nombre de choix politiques sont vraiment pas
inspiré par une prise de conscience de ce que
la science montre et donc je dis pas que la
science soit prométhéenne mais je pense que
c'est une des choses dont le citoyen a besoin
et que le scientifique doit aussi quand il en
a la possibilité par un poste permanent il doit
aussi le pousser dans la société ça m'empêche pas
de vous redire merci allez on y va on écoute la
conférence si on voit tout à l'heure voilà alors
merci de cette introduction alors effectivement
quand on parle de tanins bon on pense souvent on
pense peut-être route et entonneront ça éveille
pas une grande familiarité mais en fait c'est
un nain c'est exactement comme s'il y avait
quelqu'un qui vivait chez vous qui mangeait
à votre table qui étaient tous les jours à vos
côtés chez vous et dont vous ignoriez jusqu'au
nom bon alors c'est peut-être pas claire ce que
je dis je vais le prendre autrement sur l'image
suivante moi je ne vois que des tanins pour c'est
une image qui a été prise au musée rnis naturel
et je ne vois que des tanins vous les voyez est
tout le problème est là alors on va y aller pas
à pas et on va commencer par une histoire un peu
malheureuse qui arrive à des antilopes d'afrique
du sud les coudes ou qui au début des années 80
sont mis dans des parcs des réserves pour les
protéger d'une chasse non réglementés n'ont mesuré
sans appel les game & watch et ils sont soumis une
chasse très mesurée et protégé donc par des enclos
et alors même que ces antilopes son protégé elles
vont avoir des mortalités largement supérieur
notamment pendant la saison sèche à celle des
antilopes qui sont restés hors de ses réserves non
protégés par les murs alors on peut se demander ce
qui s'est passé et la réponse est très simple ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'en fait ces antilopes à
la saison sèche le manche pratiquement que des
acacias elle mange des acacias et c'est acacias
vont les tuer c'est acacias en fait contiennent
des toxines et comme ils sont obligés de manger
toujours les mêmes plantes ces plantes pour se
défendre un cumul de plus en plus de toxines et
finissent par contre tenir 10 à 15% de tanin c'est
à dire 10 à 15% de molécules qui vont finalement
tué l'écoutent alors quand on en est arrivé là le
fait que les tanins puisses tu étais des animaux
ça rend perplexe parce que nous fréquentons tous
les tanins dans le thé dans le vin par exemple ou
dans les noisettes le petit goût de noisette celle
où des tanins on le retrouve d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'aliments parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'aliments qui
en contiennent la cannelle aussi donc on est nous
habitué des tanins et on les connaît pas comme
des tueurs que s'est il passé pour comprendre
ça j'oserais reconstituer petit à petit la façon
et la raison pour laquelle les plantes utilisent
les tanins et vous montrer que d'abord c'est une
façon se protéger pour les plantes et je vais vous
raconter cette histoire en commençant par un tanin
un tanin que vous connaissez peut-être de goût
c'est la coumarine la coumarine c'est ce qu'on
trouve dans la vodka à l'herbe de bison parce
que c'est un tanin qui est fabriqué par un certain
nombre d'herbe comme le héros clos à la con trouve
dans l'herbe de dans la vodka l'herbe de bison
bon alors c'est tintin aromatiques certains
connaissent peut-être l'aspérule odorante où la
foudre dorante bien c'est ce même composé donc
vous saurez aussi faire de la vodka à l'ap de
bisons à la maison grâce à ces plantes là c'est
aussi parfois le foin exhale une odeur très très
agréable en séchant et c'est aussi l'odeur du foin
séché quand elle est agréable bon revient que très
agréable jusque là en effet mais la coumarine et
ses dérivés en plus fortes concentrations sont des
molécules extrêmement toxique et en particulier ce
sont les molécules de la mort aux rats vous avez
ici un pro un principe actif le brodifacoum comme
pour kumaris est un dérivé de la coumarine est en
fait ces composés là sont extrêmement actifs parce
qu'ils sont il provoque des hémorragies cdec a pas
de cicatrisation il interfère avec les mécanismes
cicatriciel et donc des cas une blessure interne
ou externe l'animal meurent d'hémorragies bande
c'est pas très drôle mais ça vous montre quand
même que ces composés sont tout sauf innocent
bon rassurez vous pour la zone bref cas le plus
toxique dans les ouvrages ce cas c'est l'alcool
c'est pas la petite quantité de coups marine
qui l'a parfume on voit quand même que c'est
des composants qui sont pas neutres et cas comble
à la con la concentration compte beaucoup soit
toxicité je vous montre maintenant une autre image
cette image c'est celle de feuilles de tilleul ou
de feuille d'érable où il ya des petites cornes
rouges je suis sûr que vous avez déjà vu ça qu'est
ce que c'est que ces cornes rouges ce sont des
proliférations causés par le développement de
petit acarien qui se développe dans les tissus
et la plante réagi à ça en accumulant des toxines
des tanins si vous goûté ces petites cornes elles
sont très riches en tanin on verra tout à l'heure
ce que ça fait c'est très astringent et certains
de ses tannins sont colorés en rouge ce sont des
anthocyanes que vous connaissez parce que ce
sont les composés que l'on retrouve dans le vin
certains de ces deux rouges et ça ça le montre
que les plantes quand elles sont agressés par
des minuscules bestioles comme ces acariens ici
retenez qu'il son petit ça nous servira tout à
l'heure eh bien elle se défendant sur accumulant
des tanins c'est ce qu'ont fait les acacias qui
était en permanence brouter par des coudes ou qui
ne se déplaçait plus d'acacia en acacia mais été
condamné à toujours brouter les mêmes que ce
soit c'est acacias ou ses feuilles ici attaqué
il y à une accumulation de tanin pour résister au
mieux aux organismes qui les attaquent bon alors
vous allez me dire ok mais les acariens ils ont
l'air de potes trop plus ennuyé que ça attendez
néanmoins on voit très bien que la plante se
défend en accumulant des tanins et ses tanins
peuvent non seulement être une défense face à des
herbivores ou à des parasites mais ce peut aussi
être des défenses par rapport aux autres on vous
savez que le noyé par exemple a très souvent des
soussous noyer ya très souvent très peu d'espèces
de plantes c'est pas qui pousse vraiment rien mais
il ya des espèces de plantes qui ne viennent
jamais sous les noyers parce que le noyer à
la fois par ses feuilles et par ses racines
produit une substance qu'on appelle la jupe
lol vous pouvez la sentir d'ailleurs en frottant
une feuille de deux doigts y ait un sens une bonne
odeur c'est encore un composé qui est finement
odorant mais pour le coup c'est surtout un composé
qui est toxique pour les plantes voisines et qui
va désherber pour le compte du noyer donc on voit
que c'est en tous points ses tanins des trucs
qui sont pas sympathiques pour les concurrents
pour les herbivores mais la question c'est
pourquoi et d'ailleurs au fait c'est quoi les
tanins alors je vous montre quelques formules de
choses colorés ou de la jupe jaune qu'on a croisés
et vous observerez que toutes ces molécules
ont tous en commun d'avoir quelque part dans
leur formule 1 phénol c'est à dire quelque chose
qui contient ainsi que proche du benzène et puis
une fonction alcool bon c'est promis c'est les
premières et les dernières formules chimiques de
la soirée mais c'est pour vous dire que moi ce que
j'appelle les tanins et c'est une définition que
certains chimiste pourrait trouver un peu large
c'est toutes les molécules qui contiennent un
ou plusieurs phénol dans leur structure c'est
notamment ce que vous appelez les polyphénols
et plus encore et ces molécules donc elles ont
toutes un phenom mais ça nous explique toujours
pas en quoi elles sont toxiques alors pour
comprendre ça je vous propose de retourner au
verre de vin quand on boit un verre de vin il y a
d'abord une certaine amertume qui est un signe de
tana mais il ya surtout surtout une sensation en
bouche que vous devez connaître et l'astringence
la saint-jean c'est cette impression que notre
bouche devient soudain plus rugueuse en fait je
vous dire c'est une illustration de l'adage latin
une vino veritas la vérité sort du vin vous être
que c'est la vérité sur votre bout votre bouche
et rugueuse ou et vous en convaincre car et c'est
légèrement votre palais là avec la langue ça va
c'est pas très rugueux maintenant avec ce bout de
la langue vous frotter à l'isie frotter le palais
est maintenant touché avec le bout de la langue
ou sans excès de nurieux vous avez enlevé les
protéines de la salive qui sont des lubrifiants et
les tanins ils ont une caractéristique c'est qu'il
s'accroche aux protéines et notamment à celle de
la salive et quand il s'accroche à ses protéines
ils les empêchent de fonctionner normalement et là
ils les empêchent de lubrifier la bouche et vous
sentez enfin la vérité sur vous vous êtes rugby
le french kiss c'est un mensonge protéique c'est
un mensonge de protéines qui lubrifie la bouche
de l'autre et la vérité que nous sommes rugueux et
les tanins révèle sa bon et ça vous le savez parce
qu'il ya tout un tas de végétaux comme les kakis
pas mûres les prunelles pas mûres même d'ailleurs
certains fruits mûrs 1 qui contiennent qui donne
cette astringence en bouche une astringence qui se
double d'autres choses si on insiste à manger
des fruits comme ça qui sont très astringent
impôts murs etc rapidement il va où on attrape la
courante pourquoi parce qu'en fait de s'attaquer
aux protéines ils vont aussi s'attaquer l'état
n'a ce qui en a vraiment beaucoup aux protéines
digestive aux enzymes qui dans votre tube digestif
vous permettre de digérer en coupant la digestion
en l'interrompant parce qu'ils empêchent ces
enzymes de travailler en les déformant lorsqu'il
s'il y est bien vous empêche de digérer et vous
attraper une diarrhée donc voilà l'histoire de
la diarrhée de votre enfance quand vous couriez
dans la nature à manger des fruits à peine mur
c'était les tanins qui provoquait ccc d'ailleurs
si jamais les tanins sont en assez grande quantité
pour qu'il en reste encore après qu'ils aient
attaqué les enzymes digestives il rentre dans
l'organisme et s'attaque aux protéines du foie
des reins etc et c'est de ça dont sont morts
les coudes ou tant il y avait de protéines dans
leur alimentation les désordres sur toutes les
protéines de l'organisme d'airain du foie qui les
ont empêché de fonctionner et qui ont finalement
entraîné la mort et d'ailleurs ce lien est un en
protéines vous le connaissez car beaucoup de vins
qui sont râpeux ou de thann et de de thé qui sont
très tannique 1 qui ont un petit peu d'astringence
et bien il perdre leur astringence quand on les
combine à des protéines par exemple quand vous
mangez le vin il paraît nettement moins astringent
pourquoi parce que c'est un un second been aux
protéines des aliments et du coup il en reste
moins pour ceux qu'on se combiner aux protéines
de votre alimentation de la même façon dans
le thé quand vous rajoutez du lait et bien les
protéines du lait se lier au tannat et votre thé
paraît soudain plus doux - - astringent donc vous
connaissez déjà ces réactions des protéines avec
les tanins et cette avidité des tanins pour les
protéines et bien c'est ce qu'à tuer les coudes
ou et les liens des tanins avec les protéines qui
assure la coagulation c'est ce qui tue les rats
qui ont consommé des raticides et cette affinité
pour les protéines en fait je vais vous dire vous
la connaissez bien parce que tana ça fait tout de
suite penser à quoi vous a rien d'accord ça fait
penser au tannage des cuirs c'est d'ailleurs de
là que vient le nom les tanins ses skis tan les
cuirs or le tannage des cuirs c'est quoi c'est
le fait que vous avez des protéines dans le cuir
animal c'est du collagène qui lorsqu'on le met à
macérer avec des plantes se lier à des tanins et
ça fait des complexes tanins protéines qui ont
deux caractéristiques la première c'est que comme
ses complexes sont un peu chimiquement liés dans
tous les sens c'est bien moins facile à digérer
pour les microbes c'est plus imputrescible et la
deuxième c'est que c'est complexe d'un 1 protéines
sont plus résistants mécaniquement et vos cuisses
seront plus résistant notamment à la pliure
d'ailleurs autrefois on mettait des morceaux
des corses ou des morceaux de bois de chêne
entre les pots pour appairer le tannage est
ce qu'on appelait la nasse et lé principe actif
personne n'avait fait chimie pour savoir qui il
était et c'est de là d'ailleurs que vient le nom
des tanins car cela vient du nom celte gaulois
duchesne c'est le temps d'ailleurs c'est un mot
qui existe encore en france est un vieux nom pour
le chêne les tanins sont ces composés du chêne
qui assurent le tannage et voilà l'origine du
mot alors c'est un mot vous savez tintin qui est
un mot d'abord lee à la ruralité à la production
des matières premières d'abord et deuxièmement
qui est pas un mot très noble et de toute façon
le tannage est une activité putride ça ça pue
l'activité de tannage donc été un peu relégués
aux confins des villes et qui intéressait pas
les fins lettrés du coup le moana rentre très
tard dans le vocabulaire académique et ils
rentrent en vrac c'est à dire qu'il rentre
avec 1 ou 2 n et c'est pour ça qu'il ya toujours
deux écritures possible moi j'ai choisi c'est la
deuxième parce qu'elle est congruente à tous les
dérivés du mot talent un tannage tannique thani
faire dan en tout ces mots là ils ont 2 ème
mais quelque part c'est un nos héritages de
la ruralité celte qui vit encore dans la langue
qu'ils montrent depuis combien de temps on sait
utiliser l'état n'a même si on sait pas forcément
les nommer et si on sait pas forcément que c'est
des polyphénols bref arrivé ici on voit que les
tanins ils sont avides de protéines et que quand
il s'y lie la terre les fonctions de ces protéines
c'est en particulier le cas de la digestion nous
a vus au passage que ses tannins sont parfois
colorées rouge par exemple ou aromatiques et
nous le reverrons louis lê thanh hà ce n'est pas
plus difficile que ça c'est une grande famille de
molécules les polyphénols et les phénols et ayant
des propriétés notamment de liens en protéines
et au passage ça ça protège les plantes mais en
fait il ya quand même des organismes qui arrivent
à se protéger des tanins et on va un peu regardé
comment le premier type d'organisme qui se protège
des tanins c'est évidemment la plante elle-même
la plante n'est pas incommodés par ses propres
tanins encore comment fait-elle pour protéger ses
propres protéines de l'avidité des tanins pour les
protéines alors je vous emmène en cours de svt
je suis sûr que au moins pour la plupart d'entre
vous avez monté la pelure d'oignon au microscope
la pelure d'oignon rouge rouge parce qu'elle a des
tanins c'est toujours c'est un vin rouge les
anthocyanes qu'on trouve dans le vin rouge et
quand on monte la pelure d'oignon et bien on voit
très bien les grandes cellules voyez ici entouré
par une paroi de la pelure d'oignon et l'intérieur
des cellules comporte une partie blanche qui est
la partie vivante de la cellule est une espèce de
bulle rouge qui contient les tanins et notamment
les tanins colorée cette partie rouge c'est
ce qu'on appelle la vacuoles et 7,7 d'accueil
c'est en fait un sac poubelle pour la cellule
pourquoi parce que la cellule végétale comme
elle est entourée d'une roy elle peut pas jeter
ses déchets dehors parce qu'ils s'accumuleraient
entre elle et sa paroisse donc la seule végétales
elle a une poubelle interne on appelle là-bas col
où elle stocke tous ces déchets évidemment c'est
un sac poubelle bien hermétique et comme il est
bien hermétique et bien on peut aussi mettre des
des trucs toxiques comme des tanins ou d'ailleurs
d'autres toxines encore et c'est pour ça que les
plantes sont capables d'avoir des toxines bien
plus que les animaux c'est parce qu'elles ont dans
chaque cellule un sac qu'on appelle à l'accueil ou
mettre ces toxines et notamment mettre les tanins
sent que c'est à la haye ensuite n'importe où
faire des dégâts avec les protéines qui le rend
les entoure puisqu'ils en sont séparés par l'
enveloppe de la vacuoles voilà ça c'est important
parce que finalement cette zone de stockage des
déchets qui permet de ce qu'est des toxines elle
explique qu'une expérience une observation tout
bête si vous êtes perdus en forêt vous pouvez
manger n'importe quel animal mais nous manger pas
de grâce n'importe quelle plante 9 lens sur dix
sont toxiques vous donneront une diarrhée ou pire
encore pourquoi parce que les plantes contiennent
des toxines elles ont un compartiment pour ça
qu'ils peuvent être stockées ces toxines sans être
importuné elle-même par contre quand on fiche en
l'air l'organisation de la cible en croquant
dedans alors là alors là on lâche on lâche les
tanins notamment les animaux herbivores ont aussi
des stratégies qui leur permettent peu ou prou et
dans des quantités raisonnables d'éviter quand
même les tanins alors il ya d'abord ceux qui les
inactive et je vais vous proposer un exemple de ça
que vous connaissez certainement bah oui c'est les
castors les castors voyez ils ont une alimentation
très tannique parce que pour le coup il mange de
l'écorcé et du bois ils sont confrontés à plein de
tana et d'ailleurs quand on regarde les dents des
castors on voit que c'est coloré par les tanins
un peu comme les tanins du thé peuvent colorés
ou du café peuvent colorer les dents des gens qui
abusent de ces substances là où qu'ils se lavent
pas assez les dents après et c'est pas du tout
ça qui protège les castors c'est juste pour vous
rappeler qu'ils ont les dents jaunes bon le fait
est que les castors ont aussi une salive qui est
particulièrement riche en protéines beaucoup plus
que la vôtre qui s'attache aux tanins ce qui fait
que tous les tanins sont scotchés aux protéines
salivaire avant d'arriver au contact des enzymes
du tube digestif et donc ils n'en auront pas les
enzymes du tube digestif ils sont inactivées par
fixation des protéines salivaire finalement ce
que vous vivez comme une astringence le castor
le vis comme un sauvetage et comme l'espoir de
pouvoir digérer ces aliments après il ya aussi
tous les animaux qui évite les tanins alors
là ça commence à être difficile d'éviter les
tanins qui sont dans les actuelles de toutes les
cellules quand vous mordez non dans un fruit par
exemple vous pouvez pas mordre entre les cellules
et rejeter les vacuoles en revanche il y en a qui
savent faire ça je reviens mais petit acarien
tout-petits qu'il faut un dixième de millimètre
et qui font segal là eh bien ils sont pratiquement
a juste un peu plus gros que les cellules et donc
quand ils vont avec leur petit rostre sucer le
contenu d'une cellule eh ben ils visent bien il
vise exactement le contenu cellulaire en évitant
la vacuoles bon alors tout le monde peut pas faire
ça il faut être tout petit c'est sans doute une
des raisons pour lesquelles ces acariens sont si
petit ça leur permet de disséquer finement le
contenu de la cellule mais en voilà qui évite
bel et bien et anin car ils ne touchent pas la
vacuoles et du coup la plante est la bourre en
accumuler plein colorés ou pas colorer cela sauf
pas de ces individus là et puis il ya aussi les
animaux qui sont capables de rejeter les tanins
qui les rejette quand ils en ont mangé et que
ses tannins sont rentrés dans l'organisme et ça
c'est vous et moi par exemple vous savez que les
pissenlits vont faire pipi le soir quand on est
au lit vous savez que les pistes mais mais les
infusions font aller faire pipi également un ébat
tout ça c'est des procédures de reconduite à la
frontière des tanins ceux qui sont rentrés dans le
sens et bien sûr conduit avec un petit peu d'eau
vers l'extérieur et au passage ils permettent
d'entraîner d'autres saleté de l'organisme voilà
pourquoi la plupart des plantes font aller aux
toilettes sont durs éthique comme on dit c'est
parce qu'elles contiennent toutes des tanins et
qu'il est urgent de les mettre dehors avant qu'ils
aient fait des bêtises dans l'organisme bref vous
avez vu que ses tanins ils sont isolés dans un
vacuum des plantes et que donc la plante n'est pas
inquiété et lava girl c'est une chose importante
de la plante qui explique sa capacité toxiques
plus que n'importe quel animal et les animaux ont
diverses stratégies qui font finalement certains
arrivent quand même à vivre avec les tanins des
plantes bon pas dans toutes les circonstances les
coups doubles illustre tristement mais ça ça nous
illustre la co évolution qui est cette grande idée
que chaque fois qu'une défense se met en place
vous finissez par sélectionner des organismes qui
contourne la défense utilisé les antibiotiques
et vous avez sélectionné des résistances
aux antibiotiques et donc c'est pas parce
que maintenant ces résistances échoue qu'elles
n'ont pas eu historiquement et qu'elles n'ont
pas encore largement un rôle protecteur pour les
plantes face au tout venant après il ya quelques
spécialisé castor ou acariens qui arrivent à s'en
débrouiller alors en réalité on est encore très
loin du compte car les plants sont protégés par
les tanins bien au delà d'une protection contre
les herbivores et j'ai montré à présent que ses
tannins sont de véritables couteaux suisses pour
les plantes car ils leur servent à se protéger en
plein de circonstance et face à plein d'adversité
regardez plutôt vous avez remarqué je pense que
beaucoup de plantes ont des jeunes pousses coloré
en rouge si vous avez sous les tropiques ça peu
de jaune voire bleu ses plus beaux mais chez nous
prenez le rosier vous avez ces jeunes pousses ici
qui sont rouges et si vous prend la quasi t de
suivre mon conseil goûtez à l'occasion une feuille
pas traiter commencé par une feuille verte vous
verrez c'est un peu astringent un petit peu amer
il ya des tanins puis goûter une feuille rouge des
jeunes pousses et vous verrez c'est effroyablement
tannique il ya à la fois des des tanins qui sont
rouges c'est encore d'anthocyanes mais aussi des
tanins qui sont extrêmement astringent alors on
trouve ça sur plein de plantain ses jeunes pousses
notamment au printemps qui sont colorés il faut
bien que vous compreniez qu'en fait ça va avoir
plein drôle notamment un rôle de protection contre
l'excès de lumière imaginez ces jeunes pousses
elles sont par définition à l'extérieur et elles
reçoivent beaucoup de lumière un moment où les
cellules sont pas encore complètement fonctionnel
est en pleine croissance eh bien ces jeunes
pousses sont protégés la lumière blanche qui
arrivait en partie renvoyé donc ça fait autant
de lumière qui rentre pas dans la cellule et en
partie absorbée par les tanins et cette lumière là
et c'est aussi le cas des ultra violets ne va donc
pas faire de dégâts dans la cellule que devient
l'énergie qu'ont reçues les tanins et bien il la
libère sous forme de chaleur et ça pour une
plante qui est des jeunes pousses exposé au
printemps ou peut y avoir des froidure voir des
gels matinaux un ou deux degrés de plus ça peut
vous sauver d'une jolie tardive donc ça fait aussi
de la chaleur et si vous regardez en ce moment
les en plein hiver les feuilles qui persiste en
sous bois sur les ronces ou d'autres langues nous
intéressons toujours un peu rougeâtre chauffage
alors v que ça ça protège contre les uv ça permet
de chauffer ça protège notamment contre les uv
ça permet de chauffer c'est aussi un tiers beevor
parce qu'une fois de plus basse est beaucoup plus
riche en tanins et donc les les tissus les plus
souples les plus tendres qui serait a priori les
plus appétant sont quand même les moins digeste
donc c'est entièrement vrai en plus comme ça une
couleur les herbivores ils peuvent apprendre si
vous fait si vous ressert un choix de jeunes
pousses ou de vieilles feuilles de rosiers je
suis sûr que si vous êtes obligés de les manger
ce seront plutôt les vieilles feuilles que vous
mangerez on peut apprendre grâce à ce signal
coloré et donc vous voyez qu'ici les tanins
ils ont plusieurs fonctions simultanément qui
vont bien au delà de la protection contre les
herbivores autre exemple de couteau suisse le
rôle des tanins dans la réaction aux blessures
c'est que quand on coupe une pomme elle bruni
se brunissement en fait c'est un brunissement
d'oxydation des tanins vous avez tout un tas de
tana incolore qui sont libérés et soul influent
de l'oxygène ils vont s'oxyder donné à dériver
brun mais en consommant l'oxygène dans cette
réaction il empêche l'oxygène de rentrer dans les
tissus qui se sont trouvés brutalement exposé à
l'air offs et que l'oxygène ça fait des dégâts
dans les cellules donc si on ti occident l'un
des dégâts que font les molécules d'oxygène dans
les cellules s'est créé des radicaux libres qui
vont aller amplifié les dégâts en s'attaquant à
plein de choses dans la cellule et bien les tanins
ont la capacité de se lier aux radicaux libres
aider les ans péché de nuire donc c'est aussi
quelque chose qui protège des radicaux libres et
pour terminer ce cette espèce de brunissement là
qui implique à la fois l'oxydation et anna mais
vous comprenez bien qu'à cet endroit là il ya des
protéines des cellules qui ont été libérés en
même temps que d'état n'a donc il ya aussi des
épousailles tanins protéines qui se font et cette
espèce de blurb chimiques mélangeant protéines
tanins tout ça s'oxydant et hand of d'embrun c'est
une sorte de croûtes cicatriciel exactement même
chose qu'une croûte quand vous êtes blessé c'est
le début de la cicatrisation tout simplement bon
ça fait quand même beaucoup de fonctions à cette
fonction cicatriciel et anti oxygène et anti
radicaux libres d'aitana vous la connaissez dans
d'autres changements coloré d'autres organismes
à la coupe ce sont les champignons qui ont aussi
d'évacuer qui compte elle aussi toxines je pense
que vous êtes au courant et dont certains virent
de couleur à la coupe est bien ce virage coloré
c'est l'oxydation de teint jaunâtre qui donne un
dérivé qui dans ce cas là et bleu et si on attend
d'ailleurs savoir si c'est encore un processus
anti oxygène et cicatriciel qui accompagne la
blessure et la protège d'autres champignons
vire au jaune aux roses il ya beaucoup de
virages coloré on n'en finira pas de décrire des
couleurs mais c'est toujours la même histoire que
le brunissement de la pomme alors l'idée c'est que
quel que soit le stress finalement l'état n'a ils
peuvent aider en particulier l'aide parce qu'ils
gèrent des radicaux libres qui sont finalement des
sous-produits d'un petit peu tous les stress et
ça ça nous évoque le fait que beaucoup de plantes
dont on aime bien qu'elles contiennent beaucoup
de tanins sont des plantes qu'on élève dans des
conditions stressantes le théier arbres de sous
bois de la forêt tropicale est élevé les grands
crus de thé ce pouce en montagne et finalement
pas protégés de la lumière du tout donc là il
ya d un flux de lumière et une fraîcheur nocturne
qui est vraiment stressante pour la plante elle
cumule les tanins lavigne dont je vous rappelle
que dans son écologie historique la vigne c'est
une liane qui pousse les pieds dans l'eau dans
la forêt du bord des rivières méditerranéenne
et dont les feuilles s'épanouissent dans et sous
la canopée des arbres on la met dans un sol sec
et en plein soleil elle fait plein de tanin et
c'est très bien puisqu'on souhaite effectivement
avoir des raisins ou du vin qui est plein de
tana mais oui que en poussant le stress dans
ces cas là on arrive à pousser la concentration
en tanins bon mais c'est pas tout c'est pas tout
parce que là on est dans la protection contre
les adversités on dirait que les tanins sont un
peu les pompiers de l'histoire c'est vrai mais ils
sont aussi des outils beaucoup plus positif et je
voudrais maintenant revenir sur nos propriétés
des tanins qu'on a entrevu déjà plusieurs fois
c'est que beaucoup d'entre eux sont colorés et
d'ailleurs nous avons prononcé pour ceux qui sont
rouges déjà le nom d'anthocyanes cette couleur qui
fait celle du vin rouge alors c'est vrai que les
plantes sont colorés en fait quand je vois des
fleurs moi je vois des tanins alors peut-être
que je suis le seul mais regardez eu davantage là
d'abord on a toutes les fleurs qui sont jaunes et
même si quelques-unes sont colorées avec des
caroténoïdes beaucoup sont colorées avec des
tanins du groupe des flavonoïdes flav us en latin
ça veut dire jaune d'aitana qui donne les fleurs
de couleur jaune ou blanche notamment ses fleurs
blanches qui en vieillissant comme ses feuilles
de ces fleurs de chèvrefeuille devienne un petit
peu jaune on retrouve ça sur le jasmin par exemple
alors ça c'est l'oxydation des flavonoïdes qui
donne des dérivés qui sont plus jaunâtre ou plus
orange d'ailleurs vous connaissez ça parce que
quand vous utilisez des bananes ou des poires
souvent elles révèlent une couleur ou descoings
ça révèle les couleurs orange ou rose qui n'avait
pas au départ c'est qu'il ya des flavonoïdes dans
la chair qui était jaune blanc et qui finissent
avec l'oxydation par la chaleur par devenir un
peu rose ou un peu jaune bon bref oui des fleurs
blanches et les fleurs jaunes voulu me regarderai
plus pareil vous leur conférer un statut tannique
mais il n'y a bien sûr pas que des fleurs de ses
couleurs là il ya aussi les fleurs rouges ou bleus
est en fait rouge et bleu a cyniquement c'est à
peu près la même chose dans tous les cas ce sont
les anthocyanes car les anthocyanes nous les avons
déjà rencontré rouge à pourpre mais elles peuvent
aussi être bleu tout dépend de l'acidité du milieu
dans un milieu très acide elles seront rose dans
un milieu ni neutre ni basique elles seront bleuté
et ça c'est les couleurs qu'elles ont souvent dans
les fleurs et puis mais les plantes utilisent
rarement ça sur des péages plus basique on dit
aussi plus alcalin vous pouvez aller aux verts et
au jaune mais c'est des gammes d'acidité qu'on n'a
pas dans les fleurs qu'on n'a pas dans l'évacuer
en tout cas vous voyez que sont le l'acidité de
la vacuoles vos anthocyanes auront une couleur
variable et ça explique ces plantes dont les
fleurs varie de couleur vous avez des plantes de
la famille des myosotis comme cette pulmonaire
dont les boutons commence rose et finissent bleuté
enfin les fleurs finissent bleuté c'est le cas
aussi des gloires du matin passera l'anglicisme
les hippos mais a un qui ont effectivement des
bourgeons et un choeur qui reste rose alors que
lafleur s'épanouit d'un très beau bleu c'est
juste le changement d'acidité de l'avs actuelle
alors nous sommes sereins terre bretonne et nous
arrivons sur un point délicat à propos de fleurs
qui peuvent être rose ou bleu les hortensias or
là j'ai une pensée émue pour maman qui a implanté
des des populations entières d'hortensias bleus
et qui chaque fois qu'on venait l'année suivante
à belle-ile et est évidemment devenu rose alors
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire allons-y ah
ben oui c'est une histoire d'acidité ce sera il ya
un problème à la bouillie alors d'ailleurs on dit
que les hortensias son bleu en sols acides c'est
bien de faire s'exposer en bretagne parce que là
les gens une réponse que quand je fais ça dans
le languedoc les gens en fait ils n'ont jamais
vu d'hortensias souvent donc qu'ils savent pas
répondre à ces questions bon voilà ça c'est pour
se fâcher que les languedociens qui regarderont
le flux vidéo wii alors un sol acide voyez que si
c'était l'acidité ça marche pas du tout en cela si
elle va être aux non en fait l'histoire est plus
compliquée la couleur des anthocyanes dépend aussi
de leurs interactions avec des métaux quand
elles interagissent avec des métaux ça change
leurs couleurs en particulier l'aluminium ou le
faire en présence d'aluminium ou de faire les
anthocyanes bleus lice or dans les sols acides
il peut ça dépend de la composition du sol par
ailleurs mais il peut y avoir de l'aluminium et
du fer libre si le sol est basique s'il n'est pas
acide l'alumium et le faire ne circule pas dans
le sol par contre si le sol est à 6 des cas de
l'aluminium et du fer ça circule dans le sol ça
rentre dans la plante et là c'est pas bon pour
la plante c'est toxique que fait la plante d'une
substance toxique elle a une poubelle pour ça ces
laves accueille donc elle met ça dans l'alcool
et c'était auxi fier sauf que dans un bagel
six élèves accueil d'une cellule floral et bien
vous avez des anthocyanes qui vont virer au bleu
donc il vous faut de l'aluminium et c'est pour ça
qu'on broie de l'ardoisé parce qu'effectivement ça
libère mais il faut aussi que le sol soit acide si
vous n'avez pas les deux en même temps vous aurez
toujours d'antan cirrhose et en plus faut pas
y aller de main morte ce qui fait que moi j'ai
jamais fait bouillir les hortensias de maman
désolé alors c'est anthocyanes on les retrouve
aussi non seulement donc dans la communication
avec les insectes pour la pollinisation dans la
couleur des fleurs mais on la retrouve dans la
couleur des fruits et la communication avec les
animaux qui vont manger ses fruits et dispersé
les graines soit en leur crachant soit en les
avalant et en les chiens ils ont le alors vous
voyez au passage de jolis virage coloré lors de
la maturation par exemple des murs qui sont des
changements de ph vaincu à l'ère du changement
d'acidité vacuoles air donc les anthocyanes vous
accompagne dans les fruits mais les flavonoïdes
aussi non seulement d'un couleurs de surface mais
aussi la couleur de la chaire parfois j'évoquais
tout à l'heure le fait que la cuisson en occident
les anthocyanes fait rosir venir plus orange un
certain nombre de deux pommes de poires ou de
banane ils sont là et puis pour terminer dans ses
liens et ses fonctions positive qui vont permettre
à la fleur et puis ou aux fruits finalement de
communiquer d'une certaine façon d'utiliser
de manipuler les les animaux il y a aussi les
odeurs vous ne veut pas être très long sur ce
chapitre mais je dois vous juste vous rappeler
une molécule le fait ni l'éthanol qui fait l'odeur
de la rose le goût du litchi le goût des pétales
de cosmos alors vous plantez pas lé pas goûté
n'importe quoi mais si vous savez ce qu'est un
cosmos vous pouvez goûter les pétales de cosmos
1 il ya des pâtissiers qui vante sa très chère
à paris un pétale le cosmos posé sur un gâteau
c'est un délicieux goût de litchi les pétales le
cosmos a fait ni l'éthanol et pour les amateurs de
grosses traminer avec ses petites notes justement
de rose et bien c'est un cépage qui contient
du faits ni l'éthanol voilà donc c'est aussi
des arômes qui permettent de communiquer avec
les animaux et finalement vu que c'est vraiment
des couteaux suisses au sens où ils sont au coeur
de plein de fonctions de photoprotection voire de
chauffage des fonctions anti oxydantes et anti
radicaux libres des fonctions de cicatrisation
mais aussi des signaux coloré et aromatiques et
vous devinez à l'énoncé toutes ses propriétés
que finalement ils sont au coeur de pas mal des
plaisirs de nos sens que ce soit les yeux quand
on contemple un bouquet de fleurs ou la bouche
quand on mange une corbeille de fruits néanmoins
jusqu'ici je vous ai décrit l'état n'a dans
leur dimension végétal finalement à quoi les
plantes les utilisent mais j'aimerais maintenant
vous montrer que à force d'être dans les plantes
et d'y être beaucoup ils finissent par avoir une
dimension écologique abordons cela à présent avec
d'abord les tanins comme matériau de construction
vous savez que les plantes ont souvent des parties
rigide comme les tronc et les branches mais
même des plantes herbacées un peu soupe long
des parties rigide penser aux nervures des petites
plantes herbacées comme le plantain qu'est-ce qui
est rigide alors c'est ce qu'on appelle le bois
bon vous ai mis un morceau de bois là bien coupés
et ckoi chimiquement le bois et ckoi tissulaire
mans dans la plante le bois et bien ce sont des
cellules mortes dire que dans le bois les cellules
sont mortes en accumulant une épaisse paroi qui
va faire la tenue du bois qu'y at-il dans cette
épaisse paroi qui fait que le bois et bois et dur
la première chose qu'il y a c'est et c'est coloré
en rose sur 7 images où l'on voit les cellules
c'est la cellulose mais la cellulose vous le savez
la cellulose je dois en avoir là c'est pas ça qui
rigidifie le papier c'est de la cellulose en plus
ça va pas la couleur du bois qu'est-ce qui fait la
couleur du bois et sa rigidité et bien c'est cet
autre composé colorée en vert ici qu'on appelle la
line in mais ça c'est une petite moitié du volume
du bois et c'est quoi la ligne alors petit exemple
de formule simplifiée parce que c'est bien fait
des molécules colossal énorme alors on s'en fiche
de la formule tout ce qu'on aime avoir qui réjouit
les yeux c'est qu'il y a des fonctions fénols ici
et oui j'ai menti j'avais dit qu'avec une seule
diapos avec des formes chimiques pas y en a deux
comme quoi les promesses j'ai encore un phenom là
vous y êtes c'est un tanin géant la lignine essais
satanas géant qui fait que le bois et bois mais
c'est pas tout parce que mes plantes elles ont
des assises protectrice superficielles une écorce
très épaisse quand elles sont grandes mais même
quand elles sont petites il ya une très fin très
fin revêtement superficiel et protecteur qu'est
ce que c'est que les corses et bien là encore
quand on regarde au microscope on s'aperçoit
que ces fêtes cellules mortes elles sont plus
là mais avant de mourir elles ont accumulé une
paroisse dans laquelle se trouve une molécule
qu'on appelle la sub erin et la subir in et bien
c'est encore un tanin c'est un tanin qui a des
propriétés très intéressante il est imperméable
et donc il va faire que non seulement l'on ne
rentre pas mais surtout surtout la sève ne sort
pas de la plante deuxièmement il est isolant
et ça ça va protéger du froid ou des fortes
chaleurs les cellules vivantes qui sont plus au
coeur du tronc ou plus au coeur de la plante et
dernière chose ça brûle super mal et ça fait que
les écorces épaisse penser au séquoia penser au
chêne liège sont des agents protecteurs contre l
incendie ça marche jusqu'à un certain point n'est
ce pas mais néanmoins isolant et ignifuges et ça
protège des incendies d'ailleurs vous savez que
ces propriétés vous les connaissez déjà parce que
nous on les utilise finalement le liège ces 2 les
corses de chêne liège c'est bourré de super in
et ça ça peuvent être sur des revêtements iso en
encore des bouchons donc vous savez déjà très bien
ses propriétés alors là quand on arrive à ce point
là on s'aperçoit que les tanins c'est des choses
qui sont massivement présentes dans la plante la
lignine et la super in ça va faire 20 à 40 % de
la biomasse végétale qui constituent l'essentiel
95 % de la biomasse des écosystèmes et si je
rajoute 2 à 15 % de tanins dans l'évacuer mais
je commence à réaliser que c'est une partie
les tanins significative de la biomasse qui
nous entourent mais c'est pas tout c'est pas
tout parce que là c'est encore finalement la
plante c'est la construction de l'éco système
mais bon passons en automne vous voulez vous
à vous savez qu'en automne on a de très belles
couleurs chatoyantes et qu'on a des plantes qui
deviennent jaunes d'autres qui deviennent rouges
et ses virages colorés se finisse tous d'ailleurs
dans un uniforme brun un peu ennuyeux lebrun de
la feuille morte et bien morte qu'est ce qui se
cache derrière ces changements de couleurs
alors évidemment on voit très bien que la
chlorophylle disparaît ça c'est certain et donc
le vert qui était là disparaît en fait la plante
est en train de récupérer dans la feuille qui va
tomber tout un tas de composants et notamment la
chlorophylle et dégradé bon mais quand vous voyez
une feuille rouge je suis désolé c'est pas juste
qu'on a retiré le vert parce que si vous souvenez
de vos essais de peinture quand vous étiez enfant
un plus on mélange et des belles couleurs plus
était brune as marron bain rouge et vert ça fait
brin brin pourpre ça fait être pour par exemple
donc il ya vraiment quelque chose qui apparut et
en fait ce qui apparaît et qui est jaune rouge ou
d'ailleurs incolore parfois ce sont des tanins qui
s'accumulent témoin de sa une petite dégustation
de feuilles que je vous recommande de faire sur
un un châtaignier un être ou un charme bref
un arbre bien connu de nos régions et pas
un arbre expérimental pris au hasard dans le
jardin être châtaignier chaîne c'est parfait
vous goûtez la feuille verte bon saingou de
salade un peu tannique un peu astringente ce
pot terrible sur le châtaignier c'est un petit
goût de châtaigne vous goûtez ensuite la feuille
coloré c'est un fake c'est d'une amertume très
forte et c'est bourré de talent donc il ya bel
et bien eu synthèse de tanins et là on se demande
mais pourquoi la plante fabrique quelque chose
dans un organe qui va tomber d'autant plus que
ça coûte cher à fabriquer les tanins bon alors
poursuivant on voit bien cette augmentation de
l'astringence mais si maintenant on a la curiosité
et vous l'aurez assurément l'automne prochain de
goûter une feuille brune est bien là il n'ya pas
d'astringence du tout or c'est bizarre parce que
il y avait plein de tanins ici et là ne sens plus
rien que s'est il passé c'est très simple à la
mort des cellules la fin qu elle l'emballage de
havas qu elle se défait et les tanins sorte et que
font-ils en bon tanins et ben ils vont s'attacher
aux protéines qui reste dans la cellule et ils
font un complexe d'un protéines qui va en six
ans balles et d'autres composants qui reste dans
la cellule et vous allez obtenir une espèce de
petites gouttelettes de complexes d'un protéines
qui a embarqué tout ce qui restait dans la cellule
sous forme d'un espèce de gros complexes un
complexe qui exactement comme les tanins de votre
pomme coupée s'oxydent et bruni est donc d'abord
ça deviendra exactement comme la pomme coupée
cas bruni mais aussi comme l'état n'a maintenant
ils sont les mains prises si j'ose dire ils sont
occupés par les protéines qu'ils ont attaqué si
vous goûtez ça c'est comme on en voit de théo vous
avez rajouté du lait vous allez pas senti à l'état
n'a pas ce qu'ils sont bien là mais ils sont plus
libres d'aller interagir avec les protéines de
votre salive et donc il y aura plus d'astringence
et c'est pigment brun là qui sont en fait des
complexes de thym ail protéines de nouveau certes
oxydé mais quand même eh bien d'abord ils ont un
grand rôle écologique sur lequel j revenir mais
déjà il explique le brunissement des feuilles le
brunissement final qui le même brunissement que
celui de vos pommes bref les feuilles tombent et
dans ses feuilles retenez que les protéines sont
complets d'aitana et que donc tous là zot tout
le soufre et même d'ailleurs le phosphate qui
restait dans la cellule sont maintenant sous forme
de complexe tanins protéines sous forme de pigment
brun que va-t-il arriver à ces pigment brun en
hiver rien il fait froid il n'y a pas trop de
vies dans le sol et en plus ils sont pas solubles
donc ils s'en vont même pas c'est ça qui est bien
c'est que l'azoté et le phosphate reste et puis
arrive une saison plus douces ou les feuilles sont
attaqués le blanchissent ou pourrait creuser dans
les agresser feuille blanche ce sont notamment
des champignons qui attaquent ces feuilles qui
boulotte les pigments bras parce que c'est pour
eux une ressource en azote en phosphates et on
souffre il les libère lentement lentement parce
que c'est comme du cuir c'est des complexes
difficiles à attaquer et au fur et à mesure
qu'ils libèrent la zot le phosphate les plantes
qui entre temps ont redéployé leurs feuilles et
épanouie leurs racines récupère au fur et à mesure
ce qui est produit les pigment brun en bloqué
sous une forme à libération retardée le peu de
fertilité qui restaient dans les feuilles etc la
plante avait pas pu récupérer bref c'est pigment
brun et ses feuilles mortes ce sont des engrais
retard et ça valait bien la peine d'accumuler des
tanins avant que la feuille tombe car c'est ce
qui permettra de retenir ça en d'autres termes
les tanins produits dans les feuilles qui vont
tomber permettent de faire des pigment brun
qui ne bougent pas pendant l'hiver car ils ne
sont pas solubles dans l'eau ils peuvent pas être
entraînés il reste jusqu'à ce que lentement des
microbes les attaques re libère les composés en
qui les composent et qui vont permettre ensuite
de nourrir les plantes et de refaire des feuilles
et sens à la fertilité des sols s'échapperait sous
les pluies hivernales c'est énorme parce que ça
veut dire que le brunissement des feuilles c'est
la fabrication par la plante d'un engrais retard
et c'est ça qui permet de maintenir la fertilité
dans les sols et vous avez ici un rôle des tanins
qui maintenant est vraiment un rôle écologique
même si au fond la plante s'y retrouvent enfin
si c'est une plante qui vit plusieurs années et
comme par hasard les plantes qui accumule des
tanins avant la chute des feuilles c'est les
plantes pérennes pas les autres les autres il ya
des pigments brun mais c'est fait avec ce qu'il
y avait de tana sur place et n'a pas vraiment
spécialement beaucoup de faits en plus c'est
les plantes qui seront là l'année suivante qui
font de l'engrais retard le plus les autres en
font seulement un peu mais c'est pas elle que
ça servira alors j'aime dire que les tanins
ont un rôle positif c'est la fatalité des sols
mais en réalité c'est plus compliqué et je vous
emmène maintenant dans un tout autre endroit
je vous emmène dans le connemara donc on fait
un saut par-dessus l'extérieur de l'europe et on
atterrit donc dans le connemara on pourrait aussi
est en écosse d'ailleurs ou même en bretagne vous
avez ici des paysages de landes ou n'arrive pas à
pousser des arbres et où vous avez remarqué on ne
plante jamais de salade ou céréales pourquoi ça
pousse mal qu'est ce qui ce passe temps c'est dans
ces grandes étendues qu'on retrouve en altitude
sur les sommets nos montagnes vosgiennes ou de nos
montagnes du massif central eh bien on a en fait
des sols qui sont bourrés de tanins et d'ailleurs
quand de l'eau circule dans ces sols c'est comme
des sachets de thé ça libère une espèce de plus de
composer chocolatées brun je voudrais ça dans le
limousin par exemple un même l'eau du robinet
est un tout petit peu brune c'est des tanins
pourquoi dans ces sols là les plantes contiennent
extrêmement d' extrêmement haute concentration en
tanins du coup ça empêche les enzymes des microbes
de fonctionner alors d'abord il ya tellement
de tanins qui finissent par être entraînée par
la pluie mais il y en a tellement que sur tous
les microbes n'arrive pas à digérer la matière
organique il n'arrive pas à attaquer les pigment
brun et tout ce qui traîne parce qu'ils en sont
empêchés leurs protéines sont finalement empêché
de travailler par des tanins et donc ya pas de
décomposition alors vous imaginez que les plantes
qui poussent là dessus le sol il est pas bien
riche puisque a pas de libération de la zot du
phosphate et et de tout ce qui permet normalement
aux plantes de pousser ce que je suis en train de
vous dire c'est que par rapport au schéma tout à
l'heure il ya beaucoup de talent dans ces plantes
et ça va faire des pigment brun mais ça va il
va ailleurs tellement de tana qui va en reste
et qui sont libres et comme ils sont libres eh
ben ils vont empêcher les microbes de fonctionner
ils vont empêcher le recyclage du souffre de la
zone du phosphate et donc les plantes et bat le
pousse pas bien et comme elles sont stressés parce
qu'elle pousse pas bien qu'est ce qu'elles font
eh ben elle accumule les tanins en plus il faut
surtout pas qu'elle se fasse manger parce qu'elles
peuvent pas repoussé elle y arrive pas donc elle
sur accumule des tanins et le cercle vicieux est
lancé dans un endroit comme ça vous ne ferez
jamais de salades jamais de céréales par contre
vous pouvez lâcher quelques bestioles et temps
à autre mange et leurs petits ce sont les terres
à viande les terres ou ce que vous pouvez faire
comme production alimentaire de plus écologique
c'est de la viande alors je ne suis pas en train
de justifier les quantités invraisemblables de
viande que nous ingérons on est à 100 150 kg par
habitant alors qu'on nous dit oms dixit 15 à 20 kg
par an ça suffit né quand même à 550 par an mais
il y a de la place pour une viande écologiquement
respectueuse dans l'alimentation et c'est celle
qui est produite la la on pourrait rien faire
d'autre si vous voulez vraiment faire pousser
des céréales là il ya un degré d'intervention
absolument monstrueux sur sur ses seules à opérer
avant de les fertiliser c'est aussi d'ailleurs
la viande qui est produit sous ses chaînes
extrêmement thani faire des chênes-lièges ici dans
les désastres d'espagne où on laisse des cochons
se balader puis de temps à autre on les mange on
a d'ailleurs une viande qui est une viande avec un
goût délicieux qui est celui de la quercétine un
des tanins duchesne que l'on retrouve dans la
viande car évidemment ces cochons ils mangent
des glands mais là on ne ferait pas pousser des
céréales c'est pas possible bref vous avez vu que
les tanins dans les écosystèmes ils construisent
les plantes et finalement un peu le paysage
notamment leurs ports et leurs imperméabilisation
ils construisent la fertilité des sols de façon
ordinaire mais aussi quand ils sont extrêmement
abondant c'est eux qui construisent l'infertilité
des sols et finalement ils nous imposent ce que
sont les paysages et les modes d'agriculture qu'on
peut opérer dans ces paysages c'est une histoire
de tanins car le sol est un réceptacle à thann
bon arrivé ici notre chemin commence à arriver à
ce son extrême vous les voyez l'état maintenant
et oui il ya du bois des feuilles qui jaunissent
des feuilles mortes des couleurs encore du bois et
oui on ne voit qu'eux parce qu'ils sont vraiment
partout dans la plante est la plante est partout
dans le paysage donc on ne voit qu'eux mais
surtout maintenant que nous avons construit la
logique autour de la plante et du fonctionnement
des écosystèmes nous en arrivons à l'idée que
c'est un à offre une véritable boîte à outils pour
l'homme nous leur avons donné plein de propriété
que nous allons explorer les unes après les autres
en termes d'utilisation par l'homme par exemple
résistant et imperméables et bien ils sont source
de matériaux je ne peux pas vous reparler des
cuirs ni des bouchons l'utilisation plus générale
du liège mais je dois vous dire deux mots du bois
et vous parler notamment d'un bois très résistant
la décomposition beaucoup de nos vieilles
charpente sont en châtaignier les plus vieilles
sont souvent en châtaignier parce que celles en
chaîne ont souvent moins bien vieilli que dit-on
également des charpentes en châtaignier des
nôtres un dicton qui courent elles empêchent les
enseignes apa d'araignée je rappelle que derniers
mangent des insectes que les insectes dans une
charpente ils sont en train de manger les microbes
qui désirent le bois les insectes xylophages il
digère pas le bois il mange des intimes anges des
microbes qui sont en train de faire pourrir le
bois or le châtaignier à des tanins extrêmement
abondante si vous les en convaincre goûter du
miel de châtaignier cette amie elle extrêmement
astringent est amer c'est pour et de tanins et
ses tanins empêche les microbes de décomposer
le bois du coup y'a pas d'insectes et comme
y'a pas d'insectes à chasser il n'y a pas de
chasseurs d'insectes ya pas d'araignée et ça ça
veut dire que la vérité populaire est exact de
ce point de vue là hein il ya effectivement ici
un exemple de bois surprotégé par certains j'en
connais d'autres des bois protégés par des tanins
qui en plus les colore la cage où les bennes
alors c'est anna sont également coloré et ça ça
a été pour l'homme une source de colorants avant
que l'industrie chimique ne génère des colorants
on utilisait des plantes et aussi des champignons
d'ailleurs à cause de leurs tanins pour faire
des couleurs par exemple la garance voyageuse
est une plante donc de la feuille de l'aspérule
odorante que j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui a un
rhizome rougeâtre d'ailleurs si vous le plonger
dans l'acide vous verrez il jaunit qui changent
de couleur avec l'acidité qui rougeâtre d'un
composant qu'on appelle l'alizarine et qui a
longtemps été utilisé pour colorer les tissus
d'ailleurs la garance tinctoriales qui est à
l'écran a longtemps été plantés dans le sud
de la france il pousse encore un peu à l'état
sauvage et et la gare ans s'était notamment ceux
qui permettaient de coloré en rouge le pantalon
de nos valeureux poilus avant que s'aperçoivent
que les allemands avaient apprécié sur le rouge
qu'on remplace sa part un uniforme en 14 d'un
joli bleu kaki homogène mais vous savez les
tanins et la couleur que les tanins permettent
d'obtenir c'est aussi l'origine du nom du brésil
quand les portugais découvre le brésil dans leur
grande mission d'évangélisation il appelle la
terre de la vraie croix le nom va vite tomber en
effet l'industrie des plantes et des poudres qui
permettent de colorer les tissus est florissante
et une très grosse demande ça rapporte or les
portugais vont découvrir rapidement des arbres
de la famille des acacias dont le bois n'est pas
noire comme celui de l'ébène pour le coup mais
accumule voyez ici sur cette blessure décomposer
rouge qui permettent de teinter les tissus et
donc ils vont faire fortune en ramenant ce bois
comme pour faire des teintures de deux plantes un
bois qu'ils appellent le pas au brésil parce que
brasil c'est la couleur de braise c'est un bois
couleur de braise c'est un bois rouge et le nom
des braises à part finalement été donné aux au
brésil le pays des braises peut-être certains
ont-ils lu rouge brésil c'est l'explication de
ce titre donc en tout cas voilà ce qui a donné le
nom brésil parce qu'à un moment l'évangélisation
et est une chose mais le commerce de la teinture
rouge était beaucoup plus rémunérateur et il ya
aussi bien sûr quelques teinture jaune je vous
propose deux jeunes et des teinturiers qui
grandit sur la lande bretonne et qui permet
d'obtenir un jaune très utilisé les colorants
intéresse est issue mme aussi alimentation et
le curcuma qui est le colorant majeur du curry
est aussi un tanin enfin est aussi coloré par un
tanin d'ailleurs si vous mettez curcuma dans de
l'acide ou dans du bicarbonate ou dans du savon
qui est beaucoup plus basique et bien vous
aurez une gamme de couleurs qui va du jour
devy fo oranges là encore il ya un changement
de couleur avec l'acidité qui est typique des
tanins voilà alors au delà de ça et et le
cours communs nous a mis sur la voie de sa
ces composés sont souvent odorants égoutter
et ils font beaucoup de saveur des aliments
que nous consommons pensons au café bon là
c'est très oxydé donc ça va être très très
peu astringent parce que par la torréfaction il
vraiment oxydé l'état n'a main façon quand même
là il colore le café penser au chocolat dont la
légère astringence vais le chocolat en bouche 1
il ya une espèce de contact qui peut être velouté
à pour des cacaos très pur légèrement astringents
et le velouté du chocolat en bouche c'est là
celle-là c'est une fine à strange ans tout
simplement et puis il ya toutes nos épices
et or là notre cuisine finalement on disait
tout à l'heure que c'était un voyage mais voyez
c'est un voyage immobile parce qu on est en train
de traîner entre le champ d'à côté la cuisine et
la lande donc fin c'est un voyage immobile c'est
un voyage à la maison la mairie ce this in de la
muscade la piol électorale n du céleri du persil
le gêneur le pardon lestra goal de l'estragon
c'est facile l'anis et la nizonne la cannelle
c'est l'acide dynamique et le girofle c'est
le génome tout ça ce sont des tanins qui
contribuent au au pouvoir de ces épices mais ses
tannins sont bel et bien des tanins aussi en ce
que beaucoup d'entre eux sont toxiques exemple
ni rist ici un excès hallucinogènes et puis ça
fait très mal au ventre donc je le recommande
pas comme hallucinogènes le leap sort allen du
persil photo sensibiliser à la lumière et font
que d'ailleurs un certain nombre de producteurs
de persil ou de céleri finissent par ne plus
pouvoir en produire parce qu'ils se retrouvent
extrêmement photo sensibiliser et développe
finalement des allergies l'amisole en grande
quantité c'est pas très bon l'eugénol c'est
tellement pas bon que ça tue les bactéries et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles on utilise
deux génomes chez le dentiste pour les pansements
effectivement pour l'alcool la dentiste parce
que d'abord ça estourbi un peu les neurones
donc ces antidouleurs et puis ça a estourbi bien
et bactéries donc ça évite le développement de
bactéries quand on a rebouché une carie vous y
êtes donc tous à des toxicités la question là
qu'on se pose finalement c'est pourquoi avons nous
mis dans nos aliments et les moules verra dans nos
boissons d'état n'a alors même alors même qu'ils
sont pas bons je vous entends déjà me dire ouais
mais ils sont pas bons pour la santé mais c'est
bon au goût et ben non les tanins c'est pas bon
vous êtes trop vieux pour le savoir mais l'état
n'a cnrc astringent saingou très fort et je vais
vous dire les enfants ils aiment pas illustration
avec cet enfant qu'il a goûté du cacao non adoucie
alors il ya un deuxième effet kiss cool
vous allez voir c'est que c'est une poudre
et vous voyez ce rictus là ce rictus c'est le
début du haut de coeur vous savez quand on a des
aliments trop amère outre au bassin j'en attends
ça les recracher et puis si on assiste vraiment
l'amertume et la strange ans ça fait vomir ce
sont aussi nos défenses et là on comprend une
chose c'est que spontanément nous évitons les
tanins mais on nous apprend à les aimer et c'est
au cours du temps que les enfants finissent par
apprendre des adultes quel goût prononcé et mais
quelle présence d'annick apprécié alors pourquoi
pourquoi les anciens ont-ils commencé à utiliser
des tanins et bien tout tient dans les deux
dernières propriété à une époque où il n'y a
pas de frigo où il n'ya pas d'arrivée journalier
de nourriture fraîche les aliments stocker ils
étaient très bons qu'ils aient des antioxydants
pour en préserver un certain nombre de molécules
et notamment de vitamines et aussi il était
bon qu'il y ait des agents antimicrobiens qui
en limitent notamment sur les viandes qui limite
la tacc par des microbes parce qu une crop qui
mangent de la viande quand il arrive dans le tube
digestif ils peuvent continuer avec l'intestin et
oui et donc l'idée c'est que ces épices sont
tout simplement des utilisations anciennes
pour stabiliser face à l'oxydation et aux attaques
microbienne les aliments et d'ailleurs on sait que
l'utilisation des épices va croissante d'autant
plus que le climat est chaud or plus le climat
est chaud plus l'oxydation et rapide et plus le
développement des microbes et rapide on a ici
une corrélation sur le pourcentage de recettes
avec épices où le nombre des pisse par recettes
selon la température moyenne du pays on a ici une
jolie corrélation montante sachant que et bien en
estonie on épices la nourriture avec du miel oui
alors il ya des miels tannique quand même et que
quand on est effectivement en inde par exemple
tous les plats sont chargés de plusieurs épices
qui sait qu'ils sont disposés en abondance ce sont
des façons d'éviter l'oxydation et la colonisation
par des microbes et c'était plus un finalement
que de manger santana et on retrouve ça dans les
liquides rappelez vous que quand il n'y avait pas
de l'eau courante ou katia pad en bouteille l'eau
qui étaient autour de la maison a été contaminé
par des contamination fécale et leurs grands
risques c'était la dysentrie on rigole quand on
entend un pasteur enfin voulait peut-être entendu
moi pas je suis trop jeune quand on entend des
pasteurs dire que le vin et la plus hygiénique
des boissons et pasteur pensais pas du tout à
l'alcool il pensait à éviter l'eau et remplacé
l'eau par un quelque chose qui a entre alcool et
anin étaient beaucoup plus sain et qui pouvait
aussi d'ailleurs servir à couper l'eau c'est ça
que pasteur dit quand il dit que le vin et la
plus hygiénique des boissons alors d'où viennent
les tanins du vin et bien ils viennent bien sûr
du raisin et en particulier si vous avez croqué
un raisin plutôt des des pépins et de la peau ce
qui fait que quand on fait macérer la peau d'un
obtient plus de couleurs et plus d'arômes c'est
les vins rouges que quand on presse tout de suite
mais ils viennent aussi des fûts alors évidemment
dans le bois il ya un petit peu de petits tanins
qui traîne et que les fûts vont donner au vin mais
il ya autre chose regardez je vous emmène dans
une tonnellerie où on assemble des tonneaux alors
évidemment au début les planches font une forme
de jupe quand on les assemble parce que c'est
des planches biseautés aux deux bouts et quand
on les assemble ce n'est pas encore un tonneau
et donc on va procéder à une chauffe c'est ciofi
si la première chauffe est une chauffe légère en
présence d'un arrosage permanent qui va ramollir
les planches et va permettre de laisser rck les
parents bas et de donner la forme finale du
tonneau mais qu'on humidifie on chauffe un peu
mais pas beaucoup et quand c'est terminé on cercle
par en bas et on va faire rechausser les tonneaux
une deuxième fois avec cette fois ci une chose
plus ou moins forte mais beaucoup plus marquée
est à sec et là qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette chauve qu'on appelle techniquement une
chauffe organoleptiques moi j'aime bien le vieux
terme franchouillard ça s'appelle le goût images
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le voisinage avec la
chaleur vous faites se désagréger la lignine en
plus petites molécules qui vont être capables de
passer dans le vin est donnée selon l'intensité de
la chauffe soit des petites des petits arômes de
vanille soit des arômes plus toastées un de toasts
soit des arômes chocolatés et de café si vraiment
vous chauffez beaucoup et donc les tanins que
donne le fut au vin c'est les tanins les petits
tanins qu'il contient par lui même d'une part mais
c'est aussi des produits de la dégradation par la
chaleur de la lignine la bière est aussi héritière
de tannins gras pas beaucoup qu'on avait dans le
malt et puis de thann a ajouté par exemple ce qu
on n'ajoute avec le houblon qui contient certes
d'autres molécules mais ils contiennent notamment
des tanins et donc là vous avez des boissons qui
sont protégés par leur alcool et par les tanins
l'alternative c'est des boissons chauffer comme
le leur oeil boss le maté le thé ou les infusions
où finalement vous avez les tanins alors si vous
voulez vous en convaincre c'est très simple vous
faites votre infusion votre oeil boss vous mettez
la tasse sur la table et vous versez 2 dans une
petite gouttes de vinaigre ou une goutte de citron
et vous voyez la couleur change est encore un de
ces changements de couleurs avec l'acidité qui est
propre hautaine bref nous avons ici tout un tas de
boisson qui ont été plus c'est notre foi parce
qu'elles ont été chauffées et maintenu scène par
des tanins ou qu'elles contiennent de l'alcool
et des tanins qui ont été plus celle autrefois
que les bas que l'eau tout venant aujourd'hui on
a bien sûr de l'eau propre on a des aliments frais
qui arrive tout le temps et la raison biologique
la raison technique d'avoir recours au tanin a
disparu mais comme nous continuons à enseigner à
nos enfants l'amour des produits tannique et bien
c'est encore aujourd'hui une source de plaisir et
de plaisir qui sont une construction culturelle
qui a perdu son fondement biologique voilà
est un as des plantes ils les protègent ils
les color et les parfume il les construisent et
construisent les sols et nous vient ça protège
aussi nos aliments les couleurs et les parfums
eh bien nous en réjouissons nous utilisons comme
outil de construction les tanins géants comme la
lignine ou la super in et quand la construction
des sols elle résulte en type d'agriculture
différents selon les sols ils construisent
nos agricultures quand on a réalisé ça on comprend
bien qu'effectivement il ya dans notre maison il y
a dans notre environnement quelque chose qui est
toujours là chaque jour et qui est là notamment à
table et qu'ils n'avaient pas de nom ce nom c'est
l'état n'a alors ça mériterait presque d'écrire
un livre à ce sujet mais la vérité est que vos
sens vous l'avez dit vous les avez vu où il avait
goûté vous les avez touché touché notamment
en bouche avec la phrase strange ans vous les
avez senti ils sont partout autour de vous et
assez injustement vous savez qu'on environné de
lipides de protides de glucides de sucres mais
cette famille là qui représente quand même bon
an mal an un bon tiers de la biosphère et bâle
avait pas de nom ça méritait bien lui en donnait
1 et de passer une heure ensemble et c'est ce que
je voulais vous dire ce soir [Applaudissements]
n'est pas devin mais non on n'a pas droit comme
ça devant tout le monde voilà et ben écoutez c'est
terrible la conférence est aussi éblouissante que
le livre et pourtant ce n'est qu'a résumé en une
heure d'un travail j'ai encore de dieu possible
la wii qui a dû vous demander énormément de temps
et moi ce qui me fascine c'est comment est ce
que vous vous lavez construit ce livre ce livre
qui est construit en huit chapitres je crois et
comment vous êtes arrivé à cet aboutissement à sa
voilà ce que vous nous avez présenté la wii alors
c'est pas dans mes études parce que non mais est
utilisé peut croiser je vois quelques visages ici
de gens qui ont fait leurs études presque avec moi
qu'ils ont pas vous croisez plus je pense mais en
fait je le dois à mes élèves à mes étudiants parce
que très souvent ils me posaient des questions
j'étais parfois embarrassé pour répondre pourquoi
est ce que les feuilles sont brunes pourquoi
est-ce qu'elle change de couleur en automne où
il est question aussi content comme ça pourquoi
le sol et noir c'est un homme qui sont fins et
notamment les tanins et donc en répondant à leurs
questions je trouvais toujours sur les tanins et
à moi je vis bon ben voilà il ya une belle ignoré
et ça méritait un livre et au moment d'écrire ce
livre cet éclair quoi en ayant bien écouter les
questions des étudiants en réalité j'avais le plan
du livre n'était pas très difficile de l'écrire
il suffisait juste d'enseigner pendant 25 ans
et j'insiste beaucoup sur le fait que l'écriture
est aussi vraiment talentueuse aussi talentueuse
que la queue leu leu goût de fass est ce cette
manière de présenter les choses en conférence
je vais montrer mes intentions de la fuel si
c'était trop c'est trop mignon alors est-ce
que vous avez encore des questions à poser ou
des réactions peut-être par rapport à cette
conférence on va vous donner le micro je crois
que c'est aux maires qui vous le passez voilà à
les histoires prix lancé pour cette conférence
est-ce qu'on peut revenir si vous m'expliquez
l'interaction des tanins avec les protéines alors
oui si vous voulez vous avez vu que le la partie
phénoliques à la fois un espèce de zone cycliques
un cycle base et nick qui n'aime pas du tout l'eau
et une fonction alcool un os h à l'autre bout qui
aiment l'eau et anna sont toujours partagés entre
les amours leur amour pour l'eau et leur répulsion
pour l'eau puisque selon leur parti ils sont faits
d'attraction et de répulsion d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui fait que sur le t on a finalement une petite
pellicule irisée qui se développe avec le temps
les tanins quand ça s'organise en mettant la
partie qui déteste l'eau dans l'air et la partie
qui aiment l'eau dans l'eau et sa organise des
petits films comme ça avec quelques protéines qui
se retrouve embarqué trop histoire les protéines
elles sont faites de la même façon en raison des
poches qui n'aiment pas l'eau et des partis qui
sont souvent exposés au reste de la cellule qui
aiment l'eau donc l'état n'a ils vont se glisser
avec leurs parts hydrophobe ils vont aller et
interagir avec les partis dans fable des protéines
avec leur parti d'en finir on interagit avec les
parties d'affilée protéines sauf qu'elles sont pas
bien sont pas vraiment à la bonne distance donc
elles vont finir par tirer dessus et déformer la
structure de la protéine et cette déformation
là va empêcher la protéine de fonctionner
correctement à la vérité au bout d'un certain
temps il se produit aussi des liens qu valence
et qui a des attaches cette fois ci les liens
chimiques non réversible qui se font notamment
présence d'oxygène et donc on passe d'un complexe
réversible un complexe irréversible voilà la
chimie de l'histoire une autre question c'est vous
qui avez vous lu oui j'en ai une sur la pourriture
blanche et la décomposition de la ligne serait ce
que les champignons peuvent décomposer la lignine
sans consommer de cellulose en même temps où est
ce que ce sont deux processus successifs alors
vous avez souvent vu je pense en forêt du bois qui
est tout fibreux est tout blanc et tous les g1 du
mois qu'il est en train de pourrir des vieilles
branches sont en train de pourrir au sol et en
fait là il reste que la cellulose c'est que la
ligne il a été mangé et à que les champignons qui
font ça et bien plus ils ne font ça que si l'on
d'oxygène qui fait si vous mettez le bois dans
l'eau il va pas se décomposer et c'est l'histoire
des charbons les chars ont cédé devant il y avait
des forêts tropicales au bord de l'axé tombé au
fond du lac et comme il y avait la lignine mais
pas d'oxygène ça s'est pas décomposé comme la
ligne aile en chasse un petit peu tout toutes
les choses qui auraient pu se décomposer même dans
l'eau elles sont pas accessibles et s'adonner les
charbons c'est aussi l'origine des charbons la
ligne mais revenons à ce qui nous intéresse en
forêt en présence d'oxygène il ya des champions
qu'ils peuvent attaquer la limite c'est très
compliqué d'attaquer la ligne il faut des radicaux
libres les enzymes ne peuvent pas c'est pas une
molécule répétitives où il ya des endroits où
on peut couper c'est un bordel insupportable qui
non seulement est faite tanins attachés entre
eux mais ils sont aussi attachés à tout ce qui
passe et du coup c'est pour ça qu'il ya très peu
d'organismes qui sont capables d'arriver à bout
de sacs qui est vraiment on ne peut pas digérer ce
avec des enzymes faut des radicaux libres et seuls
les champignons font ça et ils font ça d'abord
parce que tant qu'ils n'ont pas fait ça les autres
molécules comme la cellulose qui serait facile
à digérer sont prisonnières de ça bon voilà donc
l'idée c'est que quand vous avez une pourriture
blanche c'est un champignon nécessairement qui a
mangé la ligne d'avants et puis va manger la
cellulose après donc ensuite il va voilà et
c'est intéressant parce que ça ça débouche sur
des procédés de des lignes ification biologique
je m'explique quand on fait du papier on prend du
il faut retirer la ligne et ça on peut le faire
avec des attaques chimiques qui génère tout un
tas de dérivés assez toxique c'est très polluant
évidemment comme on paye pas cette pollution c'est
moins cher que d'utiliser un champignon parce que
là c'est l'enfant que le champignon pousse faut
l'arrêter de pousser en cuisant la pâte à papier
au moment où juste avant qu'il se fait attaquer la
cellulose parce que sinon il y aura pas de papiers
donc c'est un peu plus chiant à faire mais c'est
beaucoup plus écologique il ya des brevets qui
ont été déposées pour faire de la pâte à papier
avec des champignons mais ça reste peu développé
parce qu'en fait les industriels qui produisent
alors là encore le fâcher avec la moitié du monde
qui produisent de la pâte à papier ne paye pas
le coût environnemental des pollutions induites
mais si on le payait alors là effectivement les
méthodes de démythification sa base de champignons
serait vraiment intéressante et donc pour ceux
qui veulent vous pouvez en forêt les ramasser
ce bois qui est devenu tout fibre blanc et peu
denses parce que la ligne a été complètement
retirée et vous pouvez triturer ça pour faire
votre papier voilà oui on vous donne le micro
juste à côté de vous bonjour merci beaucoup pour
votre conférence j'aurai deux petites questions
une première sur les jeunes pousses parce que vous
nous dites que les jeunes pousses s'accumulent des
toxines enfin des tanins mais j'ai l'impression
que dans la nature comme au jardin on mange plutôt
des jeunes pousses un sonar question est ce que
c'est un paradoxe et la seconde c'est par rapport
aux landes on est en bretagne va vous parler des
landes tout à l'heure pourquoi dans les landes il
ya plus de tanins dans les plantes à moins que
vous les expliquer mais je l'expliqué comme un
fait mais effectivement là on pourrait opposer
c'est comment on en arrive là donc effectivement
on va revenir là dessus alors les jeunes pousses
toutes les plantes l'accumulent pas des jeunes
des tanins dans la jeune pousse par exemple quand
on ramasse des asperges sauvages bah y'a pas de
tanin d'accord donc c'est une stratégie qui est
jouable n'ayez pas toujours joué de plus souvent
les plantes domestiques et on les a sélectionnés
pour qu'ils aient moins de tanay parce que c'est
pas bon et notamment celles dont on mange les
jeunes pousses sont les a sélectionnés pour
les jeunes pousses soit vraiment pas tannique
d'accord donc il faut il ya à la fois celles
qui le sont par sélection artificielle et puis
celles qui n'ont pas les jeunes pousses panique
parce que c'est comme ça voilà au moins ça les
dispenses de payer le coût de fabrication des
tanins alors ceci dit vous pouvez vous demander
pourquoi vont les tanins après parce que vous avez
compris que les vagues l'état ne pouvait pas les
retirer d accueil quand ils s'en lavent accueil
s'ils voulaient retirer on les fait des bêtises
avec ce qui traîne autour l'état n'a meurent là
où il laisse donc avec la croissance vous diluez
la quantité de tanins et en plus vous pouvez les
rues bricoler pour qu'il soit un peu moins thani
ou un peu moins agressif la plante fait pas ça
dans les feuilles parce qu'elle prend vite
les feuilles se fassent changer elle le fait
ça quand le fruit mûrit un col et hanna reste sur
place il ya selon laquelle mais ils subissent des
modifications qui font qu'ils sont moins ce trajet
qui sont un film pour les protéines dont quoi vous
pouvez modifier aux tanins et saissac ce qui se
produit lors de la maturité d'un fruit pour qu'ils
soient moins agressif voilà je passais répond à la
question maintenant effectivement je connais pas
de travaux qui explique quelles plantes ont des
pousses tannique et des pousses pas tannique ça
n'a pas intéressé je crois à l'université beaucoup
maintenant votre question et rusé pourquoi est ce
que il ya des endroits où ils des plantes riches
en tanin et qui vont donc faire des sols qui se
minéralise pas et qui vont appeler des plantes
riches en tanin donc une sorte de cercle vicieux
alors qu il ya d'autres endroits où c'est pas
le cas ben en fait bon ben c'est une histoire
compliquée on pourra en parler pendant des heures
mais imaginez que pour une raison pour une autre
à un endroit il n'y a pas beaucoup à manger c'est
stressant et la plante elle ne devra surtout pas
se faire brouter donc elle va faire plein de
tanins comme à la fin le plein de tanins les
restes de la plante se minéralise rompt pas il y
aura de moins en moins à manger voyez à un moment
on rentre là dedans notamment dans les zones où il
n'est pas grand chose à manger bon si par contre
il ya beaucoup de choses à manger dans le sol les
plantes se développent elles peuvent repousser si
elles sont brouter elles sont à l'aise elle
prolifère elles font plein de matières qui
fait juste assez de talent pour faire des pigments
brun mais pas plus donc ça se minéralise bien donc
les pentes douces bien vous y êtes tout dépend
voilà c'est l'histoire du lieu qui veut ça et
en bretagne notre problème c'est la pas la mer
là c'est la pluie comme il pleut sa lessive le
sol vous y êtes et donc il y à finir quand même
par avouer avoir l'azoté le fossat donc bien par
s'en aller et donc on a des fois des conditions
climatiques qui font que la fertilité s'en va
et une fois que c'est plus très fertile bah vous
rentrez dans le cycle la plante est stressée elle
fait des tanins sas minéralise moins bien elle est
encore plus stressée elle fait plus de tanins vous
y êtes donc on rentre dans une dynamique ou dans
l'autre pour plein de raisons allez encore une
dernière si vous êtes au sommet d'une montagne pas
l'eau qui arrive c'est beaucoup de pluie elle part
en emmenant quelque chose donc vous êtes aussi
dans des zones d'entraînement si vous êtes en
valais vous avez bien sûr de l'eau qui part avec
des éléments nutritifs de la zone du phosphate
mais vous avez de l'eau qui arrive de l'amour
avec de l'azoté du phosphate ce qu'elle a piqué
dans les montagnes par exemple vous y êtes donc
là c'est bon les arrivées compensent les départs
mais si vous êtes dans un endroit il ya que des
départs depuis le la nature du sous-sol le relief
le climat peuvent jouer et encore d'autres choses
mais un moment s'installe une dynamique ou l'autre
vous avez parlé des landes bottone vous avez fait
voir tout à l'heure les landes du connemara ou où
on met des moutons à brouter un peu mais pourquoi
on n'en voit pas sur les landes bretonnes qui a
rien à brouter non pas c'est une bonne façon pas
rêver je pense quand même que nos landes bretonnes
sont un peu plus fertiles ok ouais et donc on
peut mettre des vaches dessus oui après il peut
aussi voir des raisons culturelles mais je pense
qu'on n'est pas dans le même degré d'infertilité
d'accord donc on peut bruit parce qu'en fait plus
l'animal est gros plus aura des besoins importants
vous y êtes donc effectivement la charge de viande
que peut porter un hectare dépens dans le détail
quand même un peu pas seulement du fait que y ait
beaucoup de tana ou pas mais de à quel point la
production de plantes est forte ou pas j'ai envie
de répondre ça mais il faut pas ignorer qui est
aussi des raisons culturelles voilà qu'est ce
qu'on fait pousser qu'est-ce qu'on élève c'est
aussi des choses qu'on décide parmi des solutions
éventuellement et puis les plus violentes une
autre question oui andré et puis là haut il ya
quelqu'un qui l'a levé m non j'ai rêvé oui on
reviendra vers vous après tout à l'heure vous avez
montré des belles roses est-ce que la différence
de coloration des des pétales correspond à des
tanins à des degrés différents au cours de son
développement les roses change pas tellement
tellement de couleurs pendant leur développement
à elles sont plutôt stables mais elles ont une
extraordinaire diversité de couleurs et cette
diversité de couleurs elle a deux composantes
importantes la première c'est quelles molécules
colorés sont fabriqués mais il ya aussi un autre
problème qui est très important et qui notamment
permet d'avoir les fameuses rose noire les
roses noires qui sont pourpre foncé et les
roses vraiment noir elles sont colorées or noir
delangue renoir d'accord on a mis dans l'eau qui
les arrose donc ça c'est encore autre chose lions
mais les rose pourpre foncé elles sont faites avec
des anthocyanes qui sont orange comme vous enfin
panne rouge comme vos sièges là alors ce qui se
passe souvent et c'est le deuxième phénomène c'est
que ça ils aiment pas trop l'eau les tanins ils
ont les partis qui n'aiment pas l'eau et des
partis qui aiment nous alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
font souvent ils s'empilent en s'empilant par les
partis qui n'aiment pas l'eau et en présentant
vers l'extérieur les partis qui aiment l'eau
techniquement c'est ce qu'on appelle la copie
de mentation cirque ils s'empilent entre eux et
là du coup ça change un petit peu les longueurs
d'onde qu'ils absorbent et du coup vous pouvez
mélanger des anthocyanes qui ont des couleurs bleu
et rouge obtenir un machin qui est rouge noir donc
il ya aussi ce processus de copie augmentation
d'interaction entre eux et ce processus à vous
le connaissez parce que c'est un des processus
qui intervient aussi dans le vieillissement du
vin ou la couleur s'assombrit à la sasson briel
bruni le bruissement c'est l'oxydation comme dans
la pomme comme dans la feuille morte mais il ya
aussi un une couleur qui devient plus foncée et
qui est un mécanisme de complémentation alors où
elle mais cros alors c'est vous qui avez le
micro alesi puis on vous donne à vous aussi
monsieur alors bonjour je suis là si vous avez
parlé des champignons à un moment donné vous avez
parlé du plantain et il se trouve que les jeunes
pousses de plantain ont le goût de champignons
alors c'est encore une histoire de tanin oui même
des recettes de cuisine y est qui font des jus de
plantain pour donner un goût de cèpes certain
nombre de préparation j'avoue que j'ai essayé
par contre ça marche pas des masses en cuisine
mais voilà ma réponse à réclament le fait que
j'en sais rien mais c'est vrai c'est vrai ça c'est
un goût de champignons voilà où êtes-vous à droite
du coup il y avait deux questions la première est
et est ce qu'il ya des traitements je pense pour
les potagers pour à base de tana justement j'ai
imaginé pour les doryphores prod l'appui seront
produits jamais entendu ça ce que ce existerait
puisque pour les acariens par exemple ça fait les
tanins font ils font partir et du coup ça m'a
fait penser à la feuille de tilleul qui a des
excroissances donc plein de tanins mes qualités ça
à l'occasion vous goûtez la feuille sur le tilleul
ou sur l'érable vous goûtez la feuille goûter
s'est crashé à spa valait 1 voilà c'est pas la
peine s'est rendu comme quand on goûte à 20 pas
obligée d'avaler pour voir l'homme assis un vin
donc vous vous goûtez la feuille qui après
vous goûtez les petites corps vous verrez
c'est étonnant réduit donc oui ces réserves
qu'il fait tanins en quoi ça va lui servir
puisque la carrière va piquer à côté donc je vois
pas l'utilité vous savez on fait pas que des trucs
sens et la nature je sais pas si ça fait trop ça
non mais c'est une réponse qui marche dans le cas
général donc elle se met en place après l'est pas
forcément adapté à ce cas particulier mais leur
sera quand même marginalement adapté parce que
les dégâts provoqués par les bestioles provoque
des radicaux libres et il y aura quand même cette
fonction qui secondairement limitera les radicaux
libres par contre ce n'est pas actif directement
contre les acariens c'est sûr il ya beaucoup comme
ça de réponse qui se mettent en place chez les
plantes sur des réponses à large spectre quand
une attaque et dans cette batterie de réponse y en
a qui servent et d'autres qui sont un contretemps
sauf que là de toute façon en plus la fonction par
rapport aux radicaux libres qui vont pas manquer
de se faire qu'en l'insecte vainqueur pardon
va aller faire des bêtises dans la cellule ça
peut être protecteur pour les produits en riches
ajouts en horticulture je compléterai la réponse à
la question de tout à l'heure en vous faisant bien
comprendre que quand on a sélectionné des plantes
plus comestibles notamment avec moins de tana
mais des fois avec moins de composés producteurs
du cyanure au moins 2 - d'alcaloïdes on l'a
sélectionné des plantes en fête - capable de se
défendre et quelque part on a créé finalement les
plantes qui appelle les pesticides techniquement
j'ai pas dis qu'il faut utiliser des pesticides il
faut s'en garder le plus possible mais ce que je
veux dire c'est quelque part à un moment dont
on a eu des plantes qui était plus comestible
mais qui se défend des moins alors effectivement
aujourd'hui on est beaucoup à essayer de penser
une agriculture différente on se dit qu'en
rajoutant certains microbes sur les feuilles
on peut protéger les feuilles qu'en rajoutant
certains tana en application certaines molécules
en application sur les feuilles on peut compléter
les défenses de la plante est effectivement dans
tous les purins alors malheureusement il ya peu
de littérature intelligente là-dessus ce qu'il
appelle une telle intelligence et une littérature
qui utilisent absolument tous les outils
scientifiques disponibles pour comprendre comment
ça marche mais les purins vais les purins d'ortie
les purins comme ça il ya sans doute de dans des
grosses concentrations tanins entre autres qui
peuvent parfois peut-être être les principes
actifs malheureusement on manque de bonnes
recherches c'est à la fois parce que certaines de
ces pratiques semblent tropez de terry que pour
être testable et d'autrefois quand elle pas resté
stable beaucoup de scientifiques hésitent un petit
peu à mettre les doigts là dedans ça fait bizarre
bon donc au total on manque de données là dessus
moi je suis convaincu que les pratiques de purin
sont vraiment porteur porteuse de potentiel même
si elle son petit minable je l'imaginent et que
dole dance dance dance et purin il ya beaucoup de
molécules phénoliques qui traînent talent qui
traîne et qui viennent compléter les défenses
que ne plus nous plante cultivée une autre
question oui derrière toi voilà merci corraza
bonsoir merci déjà pour la conférence est moi
j'avais une question par rapport à la politisation
des des fleurs à savoir est ce que l'état en lien
avec ça et comment les plantes vont vont gérer les
tanins pour avoir des couleurs différentes et pour
attirer différents pollinisateurs alors bon on l'a
vu un l'état n'a ils sont surtout impliqués dans
les processus de communication qui vont permettre
aux insectes de localiser la fleur il faut bien
comprendre que la pollinisation repose sur un
conflit potentiel l'insecte qui vient manger et
vient pas transporter le pollen plus y mange mieux
c'est - et ransford de pollen - il sera lourd pour
aller d'une fleur à l'autre la flore de la même
façon les pas là pour nous un insecte l'intérêt
de la fleur c'est les échanges de pollen et la
capacité après la fécondation de faire des fruits
donc il ya des fois des dérives qui sont possibles
entre les partenaires d'autant qu'en plus vu du
point de vue de l'insecte ce qu'ils cherchaient
du sucre et le sucre c'est très solubles dans
l'eau donc ça passe pas dans l'air l inverse des
tanins pour le coup et donc ça pas d'odeur du coup
l'insecte qui peut pas repérer où est le sucre et
finalement ce que fait la fleur c'est qu'elle
propose un signal qui n'a rien à voir avec le
sucre mais qui va permettre à 1 sec de localiser
de sucre se signalent ils repéraient soit par
apprentissage vous et moi on a appris à sucer
les les feuilles des fleurs de deux trèfles par
exemple un bon donc soit c'est de l'apprentissage
soit c'est des choses qui songe inné chez certains
insectes de chercher les taches bleues ou
de chercher les taches jaunes d'accord mais
clairement l'insecte ne peut pas localisé le sucre
et du coup ça ouvre ou alors pas dans le livre je
passe un chapitre entier à parler de la biologie
de la fleur et tous les détournements possibles
ça ouvre la possibilité de faire des jolies fleurs
très colorées où il ya rien à manger des insectes
qui viennent alors ils apprennent progressivement
éviter ces fleurs la médiane quand même où les bus
ils n'ont pas le choix parce qu'elles peuvent
pas savoir qui a pas de sucre donc voilà alors
la princesse et les tanins ne sont pas ce que les
insectes cherche mais c'est le signal repérable
odeur ou couleur que l'insecte de façon innée ou
apprise à ceux ci au sucre et va rechercher bien
après il peut y avoir des tanins dans le nectar
c'est comme ça qu'on le retrouve dans le miel
comme le miel par exemple pour donner l'image
très tannique le miel d'arbousiers ou le miel
de châtaignier dans le miel va dans le l'hectare
il ya souvent pas des grosses concentrations et
pas des concentrations toxiques parce que le but
est bien sûr pas fin il n'y a pas d'accusation de
toxines qui soit dangereuse pour les insectes
mais néanmoins le nectar et y est c'est un
truc dégueulasse un tournoi où sa tombe dedans
car vous quand vous avez un verre ou quelqu un
abus chercher tout de suite un autre verbe on l'a
tout le monde à voir dans le même verre est donc
quelque part mettre un tout petit peu de temps un
an ha ça peut permettre de nettoyer une espèce de
deux vastes aux collectives où prolifèrent des
microbes assez incroyable d'ailleurs en partie
d'ailleurs qui contribuent à modifier les arômes
de la fleur et construire la route finale votre
site est exactement votre question jusque là
mais c'est clair que pour mercy la biologie
floral et ana c'est un vrai plaisir alors avant
que le micro n'arrive il ya il existe aussi des
tonnes synthétique oui bien sûr en fait vous
savez que l'industrie chimique a commencé à
faire des colorants elle a essayé de faire des
tanins qui servait à colorer les tissus il n'y a
pas que les tanins qui colorent les tissus qui
aussi des alcaloïdes les deux choses comme ça
mais il ya surtout des tanins et il lance aussi
mika est fier de ça détonne un peu après elle a
essayé de faire d'autres choses qui avaient des
plus belles couleurs et elle s'est petit à petit
évadés du modèle est aujourd'hui les molécules
qui servent à teinter nos aliments innover tu
mens n'ont pas forcément beaucoup de parenté
avec ce qui est colorant dans la nature mais
donc effectivement il ya des tanins synthétique
et notamment il ya des terrains synthétiques qui
sont synthétisés pour tanner certains clients bon
à vrai dire aujourd'hui le tannage des cuirs ça se
fait sauter avec des métaux c'est toute méthode
qui sont plus rapides moins cher malheureusement
plus polluantes et puis aussi l'état n'a
synthétique qui sont faits pour des utilisations
complètement politique du coup j'en ai même pas
parlé dans le livre au japon en parler voilà on
fait des tas n'a notamment comme lubrifiant
qui empêche les prolifération bactérienne
pour les forages les têtes de forage pour fait
des trous on a des circulations de lubrifier le
truc et géographie avec des tanins par contre
vous parlez du bisphénol ah oui alors il ya
aussi des ont effectivement oui il y a d'autres
molécules phénoliques qu'on retrouve notamment
les bisphénols qu'on retrouve dans les plastiques
pour les assouplir 1 et alors ça peut être bien
loin des plastiques souples mais sauf que ces
toxiques pour l'homme les tanins entre autres
ont des rôles de perturbateurs endocriniens quand
j'étais petit j'avais appris que quand on donnait
trop de langue douce aux chevaux ça vous coupe
la langue tous les ans donc ces jeunes pousses
de landes donc elles sont pas trop ferme et ont
donné ça aux chevaux et qu'est ce qui arrive est
au chaud quand on leur en donner trop il avait les
poils qui poussait et si on leur donnait trop trop
les femelles arrivée puis avoir de petits en fait
c'est à cause d'un certain nombre de tanins on
trouve notamment donc dans la bruyère qui sont des
perturbateurs endocriniens ces molécules peuvent
agir un perturbateur endocrinien c'est ce qui se
passe avec le bisphénol alors mêmes les bisphénols
mon ami en remplacement du a finalement et qui
sont aussi perturbateurs donc c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle on interdit le bisphénol a mais les
remplaçants sont si mauvais on avait juste pas
de données sur eux donc effectivement il n'était
pas réputé mauvais et puis aussi des perturbateurs
anna qui font perturbateurs endocriniens qu'on
trouve dans la nature et s'explique la pousser
les poils des chevaux acquis en aide à l'an 12 est
aussi des problèmes de fertilité par interaction
avec les metaboli évoque les hormones allez y
posez votre question j'avais une question sur
les régimes alimentaires des humains vous avez
pointé que consommer probablement trop de viande
et qu'il fallait donc peut-être consommer plus
de protéines végétales et en l'occurrence dans
les végétaux vous l'avez expliqué il ya beaucoup
de talent est-ce que c'est alain peuvent gêner
la simulation des protéines végétales et ont
finalement empêché cette transition vers le
végétal et si cette caresse qui a des moyens de
corriger le tir oui un bon pour moi nous sommes
profondément haut niveau tout ce que je sais où ce
que je lis du microbiote humain de la longueur du
tube digestif humain qui est pas une longueur de
tubes du style d'herbivores pas du tout là c'est
beaucoup plus long un tube du site d'herbivores
pour la même taille tout ce que je lis nous me
pointe une humanité omnivore après qu'on utilise
trop de viande actuellement avec cette viande je
viens de lire par exemple que 67% des céréales
produites en france servent à nourrir des animaux
bon là c'est absurde quand je vois aussi des
animaux nourris en stabulation avec du soja venu
de l'autre côté du monde à coups de carbone c'est
absurde donc je le partage l'idée qu'on mange trop
de viande mais néanmoins je pense qu'on a besoin
d'un peu de viande pour certaines vitamines du
groupe b le cas par exemple pour pour le faire
parce que le faire végétale il y à des tanins
c'est que les tanins bien les métaux on l'a dit
dans la couleur des hortensias le faire végétales
il est souvent assez peu disponibles alors que
le faire animal il est lié à des haies mais il
est plus disponible donc voila en gros moi j'ai
un peu de viande c'est pas mal c'est manger trop
de viande et la question c'est où est produite
cette jambe solana où seuls centaines voilà face
et c'est en tout cas mon avis maintenant venons en
à l'augmentation de la ration anime végétal dans
l'alimentation alors il ya deux types de façon
d'avoir des végétaux qui tout en contenant des
tanneurs n'en contiennent pas qu'ils soient
indésirables la première façon c'est de viser
des tissus qui sont en quelque sorte sélectionnés
dans l'évolution pour être mangé des fruits dans
les fruits et un accent les fruits sont plutôt
des antioxydants plus tôt et c'est pour ça qu'on
vous dit de manger des fruits tous les jours c'est
que effectivement il ya aussi scotia en plus des
fibres qui nourrissent votre microbiote il y a
des antioxydants des anti radicaux libres donc
il ya ces partis végétales qui sont sélectionnés
naturellement pour être mangés parce que c'est
en quelque sorte la récompense des animaux
qui vont disperser les graines après il ya
les produits ont les évoqué tout à l'heure
au cours de deux questions de la sélection
artificielle qui a sélectionné plantes moins
riche en tanins ou en tout cas qui ne possèdent
pas de plein ou d'ailleurs d'autres molécules
au passage défavorable à la santé donc il y en
à ces deux pistes n'est ce pas et la sélection
artificielle finalement nous permet demain de
pouvoir pratiquement manger n'importe quoi moi je
ne recommande pas de manger des plantes sauvages
pour deux raisons 1 la démographie des plantes
sauvages est pas fait pour que des hordes de
citadins à une route et les bois donc c'est
une façon de bousiller les plantes sauvages
et deuxièmement elles sont bourrés de composés
notamment des tanins mais parce que qui un
cancérigène à la longue on peut goûter où en est
ces zones man ou pour se marrer une fois dans une
salade peu de temps à autre mange et des plantes
sauvages et c'est super pas bon pour la santé par
contre la sélection naturelle nous offre des voix
d'arrivée obtenir des variétés plus intéressantes
et pas seulement plus intéressante par rapport au
tannat mais aussi en pouvoir nutritif vont pouvoir
vitaminique monsieur oui vous partager autant
de savoir que d'émerveillement et de passion
pour la nature et vous avez fait cette première
observation en introduisant la conversation que la
communauté scientifique devait peut-être commencé
à s'interroger sur son apport à la politique du
coup est ce que dans ce que dans ce monde-là
scientifiques certains essaient de se rassembler
pour faire valoir un peu cet objet d'étude que
vous avez qui est en train de disparaître quand
même ou dans total de pas assez passé vers la
société en tout cas ils passent pas à l'égal
de ce que passent les sciences économiques qui
sont pourtant qu'on est pourtant essentielle de
prédiction pourtant ridiculement inférieur il
faut le dire c'est que c'est aussi que l'objet
est plus complexe c'est pas que les économistes
font mal leur boulot leur capacité de prédiction
1 si on devait faire monter un ascenseur avec les
théories économiques il ya longtemps qu on aurait
écrit que les auteurs peuvent pas monter c'est pas
une façon d'agresser l'économie c'est de constater
qu'effectivement l'objet est tellement complexe
que finalement gérer un champ c'est plus simple
et pourtant c'est pas si simple alors il faut pas
non plus crier haro sur les scientifiques parce
qu'ils sont aussi commencent à trouver la charge
un petit peu lourde on leur demande de carburer
pour trouver de l'argent carburer pour trouver des
salaires carburer pour publier on commence à être
un petit peu voilà enfin c'est un petit peu comme
si on dit aux agriculteurs demain vous avez été
le glyphosate et vous vous démerdez bon il s'est
fait c'est facile de donner des injonctions mais
on est face à des uns de ses nombreux métiers où
la tâche est devenu plus compliqué plus lourde en
revanche il est certain qu'on devrait leur donner
notamment dans leur évaluation l'avancement de
leur carrière on devra donner une place plus clair
et plus évalués à l'activité de vulgarisation pour
les encourager à le faire parce que vraiment on
en a besoin alors vous savez qu'on a supprimé
l'enseignement des svt en première et en terminale
alors je sais qu'il ya un vague enseignements de
sciences indifférencié de 10 heures par semaine
pour le numérique les mathématiques la physique
chimie les svt et toutes les autres sciences
enfin pour moi les utc dans le tronc commun là
où il ya l'histoire géo il doit y avoir d éviter
parce qu'on est on les vend sous les 2 pieds celui
qui permet de comprendre le fonctionnement interne
des sociétés et celui qui commet de comprendre les
contraintes externes à la société est aujourd'hui
on n'a pas ça et ça c'est vraiment un crime
contre la prochaine génération c'est clair et la
vulgarisation ne remplacera jamais la formation
initiale moi je ne crois qu'à la formation
initiale et pour continuer là-dessus on est
beaucoup à se battre là dessus comme il ya quand
même des gens qui ont pris leur bâton de pèlerin
et les vieux qui sont en fin de carrière comme moi
ils ont pas peuvent se payer ce luxe mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que bon voilà comment vous êtes
au bout de votre échelle indiciaire vous allez pas
vous battre pour pourquoi et l'idée c'est de
se demander à quoi on sert finalement et il ya
quand même plein de gens qui ont pris leur bâton
de pèlerin est donc actuellement avec l'ensemble
des académies plein de sociétés scientifiques ont
en train de monter et aussi c'était d'enseignants
en train de compter une fédération biogée pour
l'instant avec zéro moyens et 0 temps puisqu'on
passe la nuit à écrire des livres pour ennuyer les
gens mais on est en train de monter une fédération
la fédération biogée pour essayer de porter
sur le champ sociétal les choses aussi bien
que la société française de mathématiques
ou les géographes ou les historiens sont
capables de le faire parce qu'il faut du lobby
mais ce lobbying est urgent ce que nous avons
été plongés dans la crise par des générations
qui ont bien compris comment fonctionne une
société de l'intérieur formé aux humanités de
sciences sociales d'histoire géographie mais
qui n'ont absolument aucune conception des limites
qu'impose aux sociétés la nature et du coup part
dans le décor à cause de ça et cette histoire de
formation tracasse parce que c'est bien d'avoir
de voir des vieux excusez moi mais on a tous plus
de 15 ans là est-ce qu'on a des moins de 15 ans
oui il y en a de moins de 15 ans lever la main
les moins de 15 ans voilà j'avais beau être loin
non mais ce que je veux dire l'idée c'est
que c'est bien qu'ils aient des gens qui
s'intéressent effectivement et moi je crois ce
que j'ai fait avec vous ce soir et je vous suis
profondément reconnaissant d'avoir été là ce soir
mais c'est la génération suivante qui m'inquiète
où il donne pas façon les outils de comprendre
ce qui est en train de se passer autour d'elle
et celles aux outils de la liberté car c'est
celui de la santé de l'alimentation c'était
important de le dire c'est important d'aller
feuilleter le livre aussi je vous assure c'est
un c'est un non je n'ai plus de temps madame je
vous assure non non il faut vraiment que qu'on
arrête de venir là lui poser directement d'accord
je suis désolé mais il faut qu'on s'arrête à un
moment je vous invite vraiment à découvrir
le livre j'aurais voulu qu'on dise un mot
encore des illustrations de nouilles d'arnaud
raphaël yankee sont très drôle et très imagée
et je vais en utiliser une pour terminer cette
conférence si vous voulez bien alors il ya un
petit dessin que vous verrez si vous allez
feuilleter le livre c'est à la page 24 et
vous avez un personnage qui s'adresse comme ça à
d'autres une salle comme ici camarades polyphénols
merci de m'avoir accordé votre confiance pour
vous représenter tous dans ce livre et tout le
monde applaudit je m'associe à ses besoins
et à ses remerciements [Applaudissements]